committee that we have hearings this
friday
and those are all
of the early senate bills so
on friday we should be prepared to
execute as many of those bills as we can
we'll have to do it no later than the
following tuesday
so please read those those bills in
particular and if you think there are
issues
spread the word the only one i know
about is the study committee on funding
oplc
and i have an amendment to delete that
and combine it with the other study
committee we have on how to run the oplc
because it doesn't make sense to have
two of them
particularly since they'd probably
picked the same people to serve on both
those committees
all right
so it being 10 o'clock i'm opening the
hearing on senate bill 223 and i call
senator d'alessandro
good morning and
i hope everyone is having a great day
it's early i understand but always great
to see you this august body and it's a
privilege and a pleasure to appear
before you as the prime sponsor of
senate bill 223
relative to the requirements for
recovery housing
uh years ago i i sponsored an initial
piece of legislation that talked about
recovery housing and
it was in reaction to the problems that
had surfaced both in manchester and
excuse me in the city of franklin with
regard to recovery housing so we had to
get a wrap our arms around recovery
housing and make sure that it was really
recovery housing
uh format police chief of manchester
dave mara came to me and the
requirements that were initially
suggested were too stringent in terms of
the square footage
so this piece of legislation
is meant to adjust the square footage so
that it meets the national standard
and
is applicable to all of the recovery
housing in new hampshire
so after the implementation of house
bill 377 which resulted in rsa 153 colon
10-d
it was discovered that the 200 square
feet per resident requirement is too
restrictive 200 square feet is too
restrictive
the 200 square feet per person standard
is required for single family homes
the national association of recovery
residences standard is 50 square feet
per person in each sleeping room this
standard is consistent with the state's
building code for dormitory occupancy
load that in essence is is the structure
of the piece of legislation
and the 50 square feet
meets that meets the national standard
the 200 square feet was was a little bit
more than was required
uh
that that's the corpus of the bill
that's the intent of the bill that's the
rationale for the bill
uh we need the recovery housing
obviously uh we we know
what's happening in our communities
and
i've been to many of these recovery
houses i've visited them with the police
chief and the fire chief
in manchester and i see that the fire
marshal was here looks good by the way
nice new haircut congratulations and uh
wonderful to see you
thank you and that's that's the
rationale for the bill mountain gym and
i appreciate a positive vote on this as
it it makes sense uh we're just doing
good things for the communities and
we're arriving at a
a principle that that is enforceable and
it's it's usable uh and it it's uh
it meets the national standard so i
appreciate
your your positive vote on it thank you
very much for allowing me to attend and
i'll be more than happy to address any
queries that you might have excellent
thank you representative schmidt has a
question
thank you madam chair good morning
senator uh so was there any opposition
or is there any opposition
either from
god knows where or
in the hearing in the senate
representative schmidt thank you so much
for the question
uh this is one of the pieces of
legislation a rarity i might say in this
new world that we live in
there is there has been no opposition it
it uh i think it's well received by all
of the parties the individuals involved
uh and by those who are in the recovery
uh business by the fire marshal i'm sure
he's here to support it by our local
fire chief in the city of manchester and
for all of those uh who were involved
and that's as i say that's a rarity in
this life
thank you uh senator i have a question
yes
the previous requirement was
essentially per the house 200 square
feet of house per resident this is
purely for bedroom space yes
so there this says that there doesn't
need to be any
and there's no restriction or limitation
on how much space there is other than in
the bedrooms is that correct
thank you for the question
yes as i understand it that that's
that's the way it is
okay thank you that's a little weird but
representative fellows
thank you madam chair that that was
exactly my same question
um
i'm going to
continue on that line and
ask you
since i i really don't know much about
recovery houses we don't have any in
holiness
but
my
best understanding is that it supports
supposed to be a supportive environment
for people recovering from probably some
kind of addiction
and that what i read in the papers is
it's kind of like a family
model and people have chores and and
they need
space to act like a family
and
it seems to me that
maybe if we if this amendment if we if
we have that but also put back in
some amount of space i don't know if it
has to be what is it
200 but some amount of space for the
congregate area otherwise you could have
a home that's just like a row of
bedrooms with no
no kitchen no living room no
you know
space for them to get together and
talk uh i think first of all thank you
very much for your comments yeah that's
a good point i've visited many of these
sites and they do have a a congregate
area and they do have an area with where
they cook now i don't know if that's
specified it isn't specified in the law
what we're talking about in the law is
just the
the the minute of the the amount of
the gross amount of square feet per bed
for a sleeping room but the amenities
that are associated with recovery
housing i think they appear in the in
the uh
in the buildings that i have visited
there was a living room area there was a
cooking area all right there were
there's a bathroom area i mean all of
this all of this was was was available i
i think the fact that that 200 square
feet was required rather than the 50
square feet gave rise to the fact that
you were creating problems because of
the size of the entity this this
addresses it and addresses what what you
have uh are articulated the fact that
this is a recovery situation it's an
opportunity for for people to recover
you know and to have some social
environment that that's there
i think
the problem that that i witnessed was uh
some of these things weren't being
handled as properly as they they should
and i think we're we have a better
handle on that now and we're doing a
better job that this helps in in terms
of uh meeting meeting the requirement
and also providing what what you have uh
have mentioned that there's got to be a
way to socially interact so that you so
that recovery is enhanced and and it
isn't you know it's not
it's not set aside it's a positive
situation that brings support and social
interaction is very important as far as
that's concerned thank you thank you uh
follow-up
so
do you think you might be agreeable if
we um
we used what what is written here
but we also
um we move that to be a new item and
then amend
the one of the
total square footage to be something
less
to make sure that there is that
congregate area
i have no suggestion off the top of my
head what that would be yeah i i mean i
i don't
first of all thank you for comments i i
don't have a i mean i don't have a
problem with that i think uh that's
something you would expect
in a recovery house
uh so if if it's if it's implicit or or
or it has to be uh in the statute i i
don't i don't have a concern
with that i just wonder what
i just wonder if it's needed
but but
yes thank you we'll have to consider
whether this is the appropriate place
representative rhodes and then grota
thank you madam chairman
uh thank you for taking my question so
i'm i'm looking up real fast
to see
what the size of
a jail cell is and i
on a quick look um i i think that this
actually might be be smaller
of what an actual jail cell would be and
with that my question is do you know
how many bedrooms would be
like is there a
is there a maximum number of bedrooms
they're allowed to be because i my
concern is are you are you now taking
people that may need
space if you will room to breathe and
and
compacting them into a
living environment where anxiety is
really high and then you're going to put
them in a
space that is
basically the size of a jail cell if not
smaller
the facility shall have a minimum 50
gross square feet
i haven't been in many jail cells so i i
really mean either i had to look at it i
really can't comment but but but indeed
uh
in in the jail cell as i understand it
you have the facility you know the the
the bathroom facility and so forth so
there's and there are usually two two in
a cell because of the problem with with
the number of people that we have to
take care of so i don't think that that
that's a good analogy
but the 50 square feet is is the
standard that's that that the national
association of recovery residences say
it's the standard so there's a standard
that has been set and we're we're trying
to adhere to the standard by saying
we'll have a minimum of 50 gross square
feet per bed in the in the sleeping room
and i think we're trying to beat the
standard so that so that there's
something that everyone everyone can
adhere to by by creating a standard
and uh as a result that gives the
oversight an opportunity to have
something to to compare it to when they
visit these these these stay these uh
safe houses you got to have a standard i
think what what happened there was so
much of a variation in the way they were
being handled that they caused problems
but i appreciate it your standard
old-fashioned suburban bedroom of 8 by
10 is 64 square feet so it's it easily
meets this
representative grota and then o'brien
thank you madam chair
senator d'alessandro i believe that the
that this
bill
refers to
the bedrooms because this is a fire code
bill correct
this is for the for the fire code
thank you for the question i i yes yes
the fire code's an important issue and
the fire marshal's here to address that
right so and that's the that's what
we're trying to change now
and i'm just
wondering if
before we make any other changes to the
bill
we could look at what the requirements
are for
in the rsa for
recovery houses because
the fire code
i would think that the fire code for the
recovery houses is different than the
standard for the rest of the facility
well thank you for your question but i
think the the fire marshal could address
that
more comprehensively than i and he
that's what he's here for i believe
thank you you're welcome representative
o'brien
thank you madam chair
senator looking at
section 153 semicolon 10-d exemption for
recovery houses
many of the questions that i'm hearing
seem to be already covered
in that
basic statute and everything and
so which leads me to think that
basically all we're really talking about
is the sleeping quarters per se for the
individual because if not in these
recovery houses do these people are they
encouraged to go out maybe get other
type of jobs or different other things
they may not be hanging around the
recovery house for the full day they
have uh let's say in the example of a an
a.a meeting to go to maybe several that
you know they may not be there at that
full a lot of time
thank you for your quality yes that's
exactly right it's it's a it's a place
for them to be but they should have a
job that's the name of the game get a
job enhance your recovery so that you
can get out of here and get into
something else
thank you
representative marsh
uh thank you madam chairman thank you
senator for taking my question am i
correct that this is an rsa 153 because
all this is is an exception to the fire
codes so that we can put more people
into recovery houses in order to
accommodate the demand for services and
that these are in fact not licensed
facilities and therefore there are no
other requirements for these facilities
yeah thank you thank you for your
comments i believe that's correct
thank you
thank you yes there are quite a few
things in the requirements for recovery
houses other questions oh senate
representative schuett
thank you madam chair
i'll just expand slightly on what
representative marsh said and
call attention to the fact that the
language says
gross square feet per bed per sleeping
room
not the entire sleeping room but per bed
my understanding is that that would be
the space
for this individual's like individual
living quarters
in perhaps like a dormitory type setting
yes
i got that impression and i will and i
will correct myself and an 8 by 10 room
is 80 square feet i was thinking by
eight room so yes it it depends on how
the room is arranged but uh having
shared rooms of that size most of my
childhood it's
you you do need other spaces does anyone
else have questions for senator
d'alessandro representative judy
good morning senator good morning
i know kovari houses is temporarily
so what about if that person have uh
children
well that's a
that's that's that's a good question uh
the i i don't think the recovery houses
were were meant for families
i i think they're for individuals
uh
now now families in transition
is another component that we have in
manchester which is for families who are
making that transition but but i believe
that the recovery house is for an
individual
okay
all right thank you other questions for
senator representative bailey
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator
this will be a simple one hopefully i'm
familiar with the term square feet how
does the adjective gross
alter that if at all
i i don't think it
i i
i don't know to be honest with you i
think gross gross square feet
includes the
the the the number of square feet in the
area now maybe the fire marshal can
address
that question specifically but i'm but
i'm assuming that gross square feet
means gross square feet that's the
amount of square feet that's available
in that particular area
before a subtraction of some sort well
yeah before a subtraction of some sort
but because that would be adjusted
the adjusted gross if indeed that were
the case
thank you thank you for the question
all right
you
thinks a one-line bill would would be
easier to pretend wouldn't you
uh other questions for the senator
c don thank you very much thank you very
much and i call representative goalie
and
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record representative
jeff goalie representing hillsborough 8
manchester ward 1 and i was not going to
speak but i'm just going to help try and
clarify some of the things that are
going on here
this is just one piece of the exemptions
for recovery housing you have to go
through and look at
like representative o'brien pointed out
the full context of rsa 153 colon 10d
that deals with exemptions for recovery
houses
because in there you will see i mean
this just deals with the sleeping
quarters not the living quarters the
sleeping quarters
there's still everything else in there
and
properly maintained electrical system
properly maintained heating system
properly maintained cooking appliances
that is all part of the statute in these
recovery houses that's all we're doing
here is looking at the square footage
for sleeping quarters for the individual
to sleep in um so it has the support of
the fire marshal he's here he can answer
any other questions
but
i ask that you
pass this as is and not get into the
weeds because this is just dealing with
sleeping quarters
nothing else in recovery housing thank
you
thank you at
it does appear that the current statute
just specifies as square feet per
resident
and this narrows it down to merely the
sleeping quarters and that was what the
concern was that you're not
addressing the other issues but i i
agree with you this may not be the right
place to put any other requirements
representative rhodes
thank you madam chair
representative goalie do you know i'm
just curious is there a limit
to how many bedrooms are are allowed to
be in a re
in a sober home or recovery facility
i do not but i'm sure the fire marshal
can answer that question um who is here
today okay
sorry i tried to find it i don't i don't
think there's a maximum number as long
as you meet
the standards of having their proper
inspections and fire alarm systems and
any of that stuff okay
it's also
this this section talks about the rules
adopted by health and human services so
that's maybe where things like that are
any other questions for representative
goalie
seeing it on thank you very much and i
called jake berry
and ms bach looks like
good morning madam chair honorable
members of the committee my name is jake
berry i'm the vice president of policy
at new futures and if you don't mind uh
we uh my colleague ms bach is going to
testify here with me um as many of you
know new futures is a nonpartisan
nonprofit health policy and advocacy
organization we've been working for uh
more than nearly 25 years to address
issues of addiction and behavioral
health in this state
we stand strongly in support of this
bill as it would help to increase
housing access to housing for
individuals who are struggling
struggling uh with substance use
disorder uh the lack of
accessible housing in this state remains
one of the greatest obstacles for
individuals who are looking to obtain a
long-term recovery uh this bill is quite
simple as has been mentioned several
times this is uh the square footage
stipulation is just one of many
provisions of the rsa this is looking to
uh
to
be able to bring in more recovery
housing there are a number of houses and
ms bach can speak to this better than i
can who are not able to meet the
requirement of 200 square feet and
specifically in a bedroom that is far in
excess of the national standard so we're
looking to bring the uh the square
footage requirement into in line with
the national standard to be able to help
more uh
more housing facilities be able to to
meet this requirement uh for the uh for
the fire codes
um thank you for for giving me the time
to speak my name is kim bach i'm in the
executive director for the new hampshire
coalition of recovery residences we
don't run any recovery residences we
certify that the recovery residences
meet the national standard as senator
d'alessandro suggested by the national
alliance of recovery residences they
have 31 standards to meet there are
several parts to many of those standards
we're looking at many many aspects of
the homes so i can address a few of the
questions that were asked
there is a requirement in this in this
statute already that to be to get the
exemption from the fire marshal the
state the house has to achieve nh core
certification within six months of their
of their being given the exemption
within our standards they have to have
adequate gathering space for the
community to come together as a whole in
the living area they have to have a
living room that's big enough to seat
everybody they have to have a dining
area that's big enough to seat everybody
they have to have a kitchen that's big
enough to store everybody's food
everybody gets a chance to cook
individually or as a group together so
they have to have common area that they
can they can all use the bedroom is not
a place for somebody to hang out in
recovery that just as you wouldn't want
your teenager hanging out in the bedroom
all day and playing game boy because
it's detrimental to their mental health
it's detrimental to somebody to an
adult's health as well that's not where
they're supposed to be hanging out
during the day
um
there was a question asked about
children
we do have of the 72 houses we have now
certified and we've only been around for
two years so we're moving along on this
we do have
one house that does accept children but
it's um it's a very special program it's
hope on haven hill abby's place accepts
children and we're very careful about
what that looks like and that it's an
adequate home-like environment
that for the women and their infants
um i'm trying to think if they were
50 square feet
a lot of these
houses are
older properties in the city so older
properties in nashua and if you think
about as you were suggesting you shared
a bedroom when you were young maybe an
eight by ten bedroom we'd only allow
one resident in that bedroom
uh but the older houses don't have
bedrooms that are that large
to get the 200 square feet per person in
the entire building there was a question
is there a limitation on the number of
bedrooms that you can have in house it's
not a limitation on the number of
bedrooms but there's a requirement to
have
a full bathroom for every six residents
so that does put a limitation on the
number of bedrooms i'd be happy to
entertain any other questions you might
have about recovery houses how they
achieve certification what the
certification requirements are if that's
helpful for you
we're also in favor of this amendment as
it follows the national standards
thank you very much
i believe you've answered most of the
previous questions but representative
schmidt has another one
thank you madam chair
uh
in your response to my question could
you just say your name again but but uh
the question i have is
since you have a lot of experience we
know we've seen you before
do you have any written
testimony or written documentation to
provide the committee and with regard to
this bill
hi my name is kim bach again with the
new hampshire coalition of recovery
residences and i did not prepare any
written statement but i can do that and
submit it for you
that might be helpful thank you sure
representative scitec
thank you miss uh bach uh the question i
have is you said you do not run any
recovery houses but do you actually
conduct inspections
yes we do you do we do walk-throughs we
measure the bedrooms we count the
bathrooms we're looking at um we're as
well as
as mr toomey's office we are looking at
safety systems we're checking smoke
detectors we set them all off we're
looking at egresses from every bedroom
to make sure that that's proper
that they have
adequate safe
ethically run homes
okay thank you miss bach other questions
uh representative marsh
yes thank you madam chairman i'm looking
at both of these sketches here uh and it
it's
can you can you tell me if i'm correct
because
you are voluntarily certifying safe
houses and it seems to me that what
we're doing here is we've created an
exemption from the fire code for such
safe houses that choose to be
voluntarily certified which therefore
would not apply to any other safe houses
which might not choose to be certified
are there any uncertified state house
safe houses in new hampshire there's a
large number as i said we've only been
in existence for two years so being up
to 72 houses already i feel like we're
chugging right along
but it takes time to get everybody
certified
there's also a restriction on funding
availability for
recovery houses that's set by dhhs
so if you want assistance financial
assistance in the form of
rental assistance for people coming in
you have to be certified
one one follow-up question um
since only certified safe houses uh
can fall into this exemption and your
certification requires all these various
other things like a living area in the
kitchen and that sort of thing uh would
it not be true that it would be
unnecessary for us to put those
requirements into the fire code
exemption
i would agree with you i would agree
with you
yeah
okay if i could add just very briefly
with the work that kim and nh core are
doing along with work through the new
hampshire department of health and human
services there has been a a broad effort
to increase the the regulation and
safety protocols around recovery houses
and again this is just intended to be a
very minor tweak to be able to help uh
to help more houses uh be able to secure
this exemption be able to uh uh
to be able to conduct safe uh operations
and to support individuals in recovery
so again there is a large backdrop here
this is just a minor tweak and if i
could just reinforce what senator
d'alessandro said there's really no
opposition to this the homes are on
board the the
regulators are on board and certainly i
think i can speak for members of the
provider community who feel that this is
a an important uh way to support
recovery housing
thank you are there other questions
there's no scitec
uh this is the bill seems fine to me but
there i've
i'm puzzled by something you certify
houses but you're not a municipal agency
you're not you're not the fire
department you're not the health officer
how are you inspect what gives you the
right to inspect what does your
certification mean
means they can get money from hhs for
one thing
sure that's what she said and i would
imagine that's a powerful incentive
that's a powerful incentive and we're
the state affiliate for the national
alliance of recovery residences and
there are a lot of houses that come to
us because they want to advertise that
they are doing it right
this is an area where abuse can happen
and having the certification is a really
powerful tool for them
thank you i'm all for it but it sounds
odd you're a private agency aren't you
doing it
doing a
certification that the hhs accepts
is that that's correct okay great thank
you that that applies in other things
too okay other questions
seeing none thank you very much
thank you
marshall toomey
good morning thank you my name is sean
toomey i'm state fire marshal and with
the hopes of not complicating things too
much more but
i do we i support the bill and the fire
marshal's office supports the bill the
board of fire control has been actively
involved in this they also support their
change
where we kind of landed in this we've
worked closely with new hampshire corps
and recovery communities the fire chiefs
and the court officials over the last
several years and we landed with house
bill 377 and that included the 200
square feet
over since we've implemented it we
realized we needed a slight change in a
cleanup so
how we got here in the first place was
from the code perspective we look at one
or two family homes much like we
probably live in or
you look into apartments or you look at
hotels or dorms you look at lodging and
rooming and most of these ended up in
the classification of lodging and
rooming and it required more robust fire
protection requirements that were a
little bit bursting to the recovery uh
community and what we learned through
some federal um cases that went through
is that uh if we enforce the uh
requirements of lodging and rooming on
the facilities it would be
discriminatory because they're
considered uh in need of an
accommodation because they're in
recovery so we've we worked closely to
try to come up with a reasonable
solution and we uh codified it through
the the statutes in the last through
house bill 377 last session and came up
with the list the fire marshal's office
and myself now could uh
issue an exemption to if they're
properly operating as a recovery health
certified through you know following the
nars standard following new hampshire
core new hampshire corps does the
assessment initially we work closely
with the local fire departments do
inspections and we issue a variance and
do a visit for each of these facilities
the 200 square feet was just too much it
was going to end up closing a lot of the
facilities that were in existence and
that clearly wasn't necessary we had
been in many of the facilities and we
realized that it was just the 200 was
too big
when we initially did house bill 377
we needed a number that would seem
reasonable and we just didn't want to
pull a number out of thin air we used
200 square feet because that was what
was in residential other than
single-family homes uh so we had
something we can go to uh that was
already instead in the the codes
building in fire codes without just
making a number up because we didn't
want to discriminate against people in
recovery
once as we've processed these almost 72
now
we're like well this just doesn't this
doesn't work so we went to the nar
standard and then we were we wanted to
uh match it with something that was in
the codes the codes now for a dorm
setting is 50 square feet so that's
where we came up with the 50s it matched
nicely within our standard it matched
nicely with what was already in our
existing building and fire codes as a
dorm for 50 square feet so i hope that
provides a little bit of context and
background but i think that i mean we
it has wholesale support um and it's i
think it's for the betterment of the
recovery support in the recovery
community and happy to answer any
questions
thank you marshall are there any
yes representative schuett thank you
madam chair thank you mr marshall um
based on what you just said um
would you say
i i realize the analysis does not say
that your office
requested this legislation
but uh recommended would that be a good
word to use i would feel comfortable
saying recommend we were definitely
supportive of it we were behind we were
with the uh governor's office named
score in our office everyone trying to
come up with a solution in the beginning
uh so yeah we're we're fully supportive
all in a way of
instituting this change thank you you're
welcome representative o'brien
thank you madam chip thank you marshall
for taking the question uh you've heard
a lot of the debate and many of the
questions that went on in reviewing what
you've heard as far as questions from
this body do you see any amendments in
need to spill the need of any amendments
or anything or do you think it's
satisfactory as it stands alone thank
you for the question i wouldn't
recommend any further changes at this
point i don't think we want to
complicate matters any having been in
many many uh houses throughout the state
at this point i think this is a great
solution hopefully will
put us in a really good spot to
support these facilities
okay thank you other questions
representative pearson
thank you madam chair marshall toomey
the
voluntary certification by new hampshire
core
um they just touted their the
inspections that they conduct
would it be correct in in a line of
thinking that that does not
alleviate that's a wrong word it does
not take the place of a local
municipality conducting their own
inspections as a municipal fire agency
that's correct part of the variance
approval is a
a a
an annual inspection by the local fire
department so that in addition to the
new hampshire corps maintaining new
hampshire core certification which is
part of this process and a link to dhhs
funding there is a requirement for local
fire inspections annually to make sure
the safety features are in place they're
still operating under the parameters of
the 153 10d
everything's safe you know the systems
are still maintained and they're they're
operating under that recovery model
which is uh considered family-like
social living thank you
other questions representative fellow
um
let's see
so
just to clarify just uh two little
questions one of them the 200 square
feet that would have
that's what applies to places like
assisted living
or because it's not not a home and it's
not a dorm
i can't remember the chart of my top of
my head for assist living i think more
of an like an apartment building would
be more appropriate for the 200 square
feet would be one or a hotel would be
200 square feet
um
a dorm like a college dorm would be down
in the 50 but
i don't remember the assist living and
my other question is there any um
for the
for the recovery homes is there any
limit on the number of residents there
could be i mean you know i know most of
them are probably like 10 or 20 but
could there be 50
i've not seen any that large it would be
require a pretty significantly sized
house to make that happen and
uh the 50 square feet remember a couple
things it would the the bedroom size has
to be supported by the other stuff in
the house and for instance other things
that come into play if there are houses
in a rural area in new hampshire and
it's on septic
the septic is going to drive the number
of bedrooms as well so there's some ties
there in concord or manchester it's
going to be driven by the number of
bedrooms in the in general so
you know some things we'll also look at
but no bedrooms in the in the basements
or an attic stuff them in an attic or
things like that you know some of the
early early ones we were in and seeing
is that people were in basements
they were putting multiple bunk beds
crammed into a room
this 50 is really
we've found so far that it's it's
satisfactory and it meets the intent and
provides a safe living situation
okay thank you are there other questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much thank you to me
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 223
all right seeing none
we're going to close the hearing
and we'll be opening the hearing on
senate bill 398.
good morning senator
good morning madam chair for the record
my name is sharon carson i have the
pleasure of representing senate district
14 comprising the towns of londonderry
hudson and auburn and i have for your
consideration this morning senate bill
398 relative to the building code and
fire code enforcement
this bill came out of a study committee
that
worked i believe in the summer of 2018
myself
your chair representative of
representative
oh my goodness i can't remember
maguire
as well as senator guida the three of us
worked on this issue
because there was a lot of
a lot of problems getting
codes passed in the house and we wanted
to work on a way
in order to facilitate
those codes here
in the in the legislature because i
think we all know that we do have these
codes and they need to be updated
periodically as well as amendments
needing to get passed and so
the bill was filed and it was heard in
the senate it was then
held over for more work because of the
information we received at the public
hearing
and it came forward and then we went
into uh lockdown
because of coven and it was placed into
an omnibus bill and it died in one of
the omnibus bills that was not passed by
the house
i was asked to bring it forward again
this year and so that is what you have
in front of us so just to kind of walk
you through
um what this bill does it's the first
thing it does is it clarifies that the
issuance of a permit and the collection
of fees shall not be considered as an
amendment to the building code
to the building code itself let me take
a step back we had the public hearing in
the senate there were some suggestions
that were made by both the fire
marshal's office and the
building code review board
and what you have in front of you as
amended by the senate are there are
their recommendations so the first is
they want to make it very clear
that if you get a permit or there's a
collection of fees it's there it's not
considered to be an amendment to the
building code review uh the
the building codes i should say secondly
no fee is required to appeal a notice of
violation or any decision of a code
official
third it deals with the state-wide
amendments to the building code that
they are to be reviewed and approved by
the board then they're submitted to the
legislature before becoming effective
third excuse me fourth the board shall
review a newer version of the code that
has been published for two years because
we we've kind of made the decision that
we're going to try to stay two years
behind
so that gives both the fire marshal's
office as well as the state uh building
code review board an opportunity to go
over those boards uh excuse me to go
over those proposed courts court
codes and then make a decision about
what they want to send to the
legislature
and then finally is an issue dealing
with municipal amendments one of the
things that we discovered was that
municipalities tend to adopt their own
codes as ordinances and oftentimes those
codes go way beyond what the state
building code review board has
authorized or the legislature has
authorized
this makes it difficult for trades
persons when they go from community to
community instead of having one document
that they're working off of
they're dealing with a different
document in every single community and
that can make it harder for them to do
their jobs
so
what everyone came up with was a
procedure that first that
a municipality shall submit proposed
amendments to the board for review prior
to adoption
we're not saying that you have to get
them approved by the board but the board
just wants to take a look to review
whatever amendments that you want to
adopt for your community
second it allows for an advisory opinion
where the building code review board can
take a look at that and they can say
well you know this is what we think
about this proposed amendment
third it looks to see that the proposed
amendment does not establish a
requirement which conflicts with or are
less stringent than the most recent
statewide building code that's been
approved by the legislature and there
are no conflicts with the fire code
itself again what we're trying to get to
do is to get everyone on the same page
when it comes to these building codes
and then finally
they're published by the board
so that way anyone who a trades person
who's work looking to work in any
community
knows that i can go and look at these
building codes they're all updated in
one place instead of having to go to
each municipality and dig through those
codes to find out which ones are
different
so
at this point madam chair i'm going to
conclude my testimony i will try to
answer questions but i am not a building
code official
we do have individuals who are here that
have worked on this
with the building code review board and
fire marshal twomey is here to answer
any questions that you might have thank
you very much madam chair
thank you representative lekkis
uh thank you madam chair just one
question um
and that is it was my understanding that
we've been updating the building codes
every three years and part of the reason
for that was to see
how they worked out elsewhere and if
there were problems
and apparently this drops that down to
two years and i'm wondering why that was
done if if i'm correct
thank you very much if my memory serves
me correct it was we did just didn't
want to get too far behind
um there has been a lot of difficulty in
getting
codes passed by the legislature
and if we wait too long we get too far
behind and what ends up happening
is
insurance rates go up for either a
builder for building a single-family
home again that cost gets put off to the
new buyer or for commercial developments
as well
there is a fire and safety code we do
not want to get too far behind on that
code either because we are dealing about
the safety of individuals that are in
hospitals nursing homes and other places
and we thought two years would would is
a workable schedule
and we have just gone through
what i guess you would call the first
cycle of the two years and what's really
working out well is everyone is working
together
and that's why and it has made it much
much easier to uh to get these things
looked at and to get them passed thank
you thank you
representative o'brien
thank you madam chair uh thank you
senator for taking the question looking
at the bill on line 12
section 4 the committee shall work with
the building code review board and the
board of fire control when you mention
the board of fire control
would it be better to specify the i
would assume that means the state fire
marshal
thank you for your question i think um
when we we were talking about the board
we were talking about the the building
code review board
um
and that is excuse me not to interrupt
you
but so the
uh board of fire control is the building
called reveal board it's my
understanding that there's two separate
boards one is the fire board and the
other is the state building code review
board um the fire marshal is telling me
correctly if you folks want to clarify
or add in the fire board as well that's
fine with me
okay i'll withhold that question madam
chair and if the fire marshal's going to
testify thank you thank you senator
you're welcome
representative pearson did you want to
respond to that
you and i can talk i can explain if
if you need it but i think the marshall
will take care of it
representative schuett
thank you madam chair uh
senator would you say that if we
went back and just
approved these every three years as
opposed to every two years that that
results in a lot more changes going
forward for people to
try and
digest and comply with
thank you for the question yes i would
agree with that and if you have every
three years um
you're dealing with a different
oftentimes a different group of people
um because we are elected for two years
in a two-year cycle so you could have
the board be working on something and
then come forward and now the sudden
you've got
a new group of people who really don't
understand and they have to get caught
up on this and it will make it i think a
little bit harder and heaven forbid you
fall
into a budget year
where
a lot of people are just really focused
on the budget itself
representative grota
thank you madam chair
senator carson um
the building codes are
a minimum
are the state minimum
so this would not prevent municipalities
to in
to put in ordinances
codes that are
more stringent is that correct
all this does thank you for the question
all this does is it it creates a
mechanism for the building code review
board to look at those amendments
and to talk with the municipality and
say this is more stringent or this is
less stringent but it doesn't prevent
them from adopting them okay in the
original legislation that i had filed
that said if the building code review
board said this is not good they
couldn't adopt that but the
municipalities were very
upset about that
and we don't want to tread on their toes
we just want to try to get everybody on
the same page
follow up
sir
so in municipalities that don't have
a building inspector
or um
how do they
then
how do we
ensure that
the
constructions that being it's being done
in those
municipalities does meet the building
code well thank you for the question um
i don't feel that i'm in a position to
make that kind of a an assessment but i
know that uh building code
building code review board folks are
here as well as the fire marshal and i
believe that
i want to say maybe a year ago or maybe
two
we had legislation that would allow the
state fire marshal to be the inspecting
um
uh entity
on places that do not have building
codes
a person to look for that stuff the
vectors okay thank you but they will
answer that question better than i can
thank you
thank you very much senator thank you
marshall toomey
i understand you want to testify correct
i forgot about representative mcguire's
card i put in the card
thank you madam chair members of
committee i'm carol mcguire representing
merrimack district 29
which is allenstown epsom in pittsfield
senate bill 398 was amended by the
senate and it is now a much simpler bill
because most of the content that the
senator was speaking about was
incorporated into house bill 1681
which we passed earlier this year
has been passed by the senate edna
committee and the senate and is now in
in senate finance
although i'm not sure why
but it is in senate finance and
it's expected to be approved
so what this bill as amended primarily
does
is it
reconstitutes the joint committee on
code enforcement and advisory committee
on state building and fire code
it it consolidates them into one
advisory committee that essentially
would be the legislative liaison
to the building code
review board and the board of fire
control
requires them to work with them start
planning when to introduce legislation
to update codes
and report annually
so that we can continue in the process
of updating so there were only one code
cycle behind which is what the what what
the plan is the state building code
review board has started looking at the
2021 codes
they're not ready for adoption but
not this session
next session would be appropriate
there's also a
grace period established in the building
code that's section 2 of the bill
starting on line 23
that is a
simplified version of what we approved
in
house bill 1681 and the committee might
want to think about deleting it from
this bill
because as i said it's
it's a simplified
um
a simplified paragraph with the same
intent namely that if you're doing a
major project you don't have to worry
about when a code chain comes in the the
code when you get your building permit
is what applies
and i will try to answer questions
thank you madam chair um madam chair
um just just so that i understand
building codes in general because i
don't believe my town has any
of those
um is is it correct that
the state will publish these building
codes
kind of as a model no no the state
building code is effective throughout
the state
it is passed by the legislature and
the building code review board and it
applies throughout the state and and
even to towns that don't have building
inspectors
if you do something in a town that does
not have a building inspector such as my
town
you the person who builds the house is
responsible for making sure it meets the
code
or and it may be inspected
or it may not be but it's still the
owner's responsibility to do so
and the state fire marshal i i believe
and the building code review board help
with
major projects that are outside of
outside of the towns that do have these
officials
a town may adopt a
ch an amendment to the building to the
building code
that is more stringent than the base
code
and but house bill 1681 requires it to
be
sent to the
building code review board for approval
and do they have the option to
say that they don't want to follow one
presid
provision or
only if they are making it more
stringent by doing so okay thank you
see no further questions
thank you very much thank you
thank you chairman
marshall toomey
good morning again sean toomey the state
fire marshal i think uh codes are
probably one of the most confusing
things out there frankly um
uh so sorry for the we were doing this
crash course on education for you
tonight so senator this morning senator
carson i think gave a great background
on of the package of where we're at and
sort of where we're landed with some of
the senate bill 398 and representative
mcguire i think helped clean up some of
the amendments so we have multiple bills
as you recall probably there's a couple
more coming to you on uh building and
fire code items now we're really i think
it's the culmination of a lot of cleanup
over the last few years and really
trying to streamline the the process of
code development in the state so
a quick note on 398 uh
the part of it as representative mcguire
mentioned the joint committee on code
enforcement was established in 1999 and
it was pre uh state building code so
that was at a time where each
municipality did their own building code
work uh in 1999 and established a joint
committee on code enforcement which is
kind of a subset of the board of fire
control and it brought together
different representatives professional
engineers building officials fire
officials
water well board and others architects
to try to talk about common concerns
around code enforcement
and kind of come up with a plan to go to
a state building code once that happened
the board uh building code review board
was established and the the kind of the
useful life of the joint committee on
code enforcement is no longer so this
bill uh eliminates the joint committee
on co-enforcement and establishes in its
place the advisory committee that
representative mcguire spoke to so that
the building code review board and the
board of fire control can feed up an
annual report to the legislature sort of
a summary of its activity over the last
year of any necessary whether it's
amendments that come forward for the
building or the fire code side or
proposals for a wholesale update to the
fire code and staying with that
three-year cycle the two-year part of it
is we have to be published for at least
two years before the either board
considers
updating a wholesale code so we're in
the 15 codes now the 18 is about to be
hopefully uh processed this uh committee
in the house already approved it it's as
we heard it's in senate finance right
now and that should go through we'll
that will get us on the 18 codes with
new hampshire amendments the new
hampshire amendments are heard at the
board of fire control for fireside
building code reboot for the building
side so that cleans up that in a little
bit of history and i think uh providing
the advisory committee on state building
and fire codes at the legislative level
is a great thing that we have uh
kind of support and thought process
earlier into the process on the
legislative side coming out of the two
boards so i think that'll be a good
thing
and as representative mcguire mentioned
starting at line 23 the grace period
that landed in a couple different spots
and it would be more than appropriate
for this committee to eliminate that
section the new paragraph starting at
line 23 on the grace period because it's
also in house bill 1681
and it's more detailed in 1681 so happy
to answer any questions hope that
provided a little bit of background
pearson thank you
madam chair
as
marshall toomey as you and i are in
their unique uh circumstance of both
having advanced degrees in this field
my concern and i and i'm just asking if
this will address that is that we have
local
especially local fire inspectors that
invent their own engineering degrees
okay
and
that's been a a issue not only just for
the builders because
the builders are the builders deal with
what they deal with but joe homeowner
especially having to deal with something
that has come out of nowhere that really
cannot be cited or
referenced in any sort of real and
logical way
does this provide the ability for
john q public when they have an issue
with a local fire official that's
inventing his engineering degree to come
before the state
and have that decision reviewed
that would be in senate bill 443
that put that portion of it on the
building side the fire side of it is not
in there right now it's not in 443 no no
that ended up being amended in the
building side of its own in there now i
spoke with a representative from the
ecba steve raincord with probably many
of you familiar with yesterday and
they're looking to add it in and we
would support it as long as the process
follows what we did we established on
the building side so uh okay great thank
you you're welcome
representative schmidt
thank you madam chair um fire marshal i
want to bring you back to
your remarks before representative
pearson
has uh interrogated you you met
referenced in the bill on line 23 and
following uh could you uh
repeat that just so we get it right did
i hear you correctly that you want to
you suggest that we uh strip that out of
the bill yes yeah so starting at line 23
down through
ending at 29
29 would be appropriate that that's
covered in house bill 1681 which was
already passed by the house and as i
said is in senate finance right now
thank you
welcome very helpful
see no further questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
mr sherman
good morning my name is phillip sherman
i speak as the chair of the building
code review board i speak in favor of
this bill
i strongly support the concept of a
standing legislative committee which
will lead to positive work and
relationships between the bcrb and the
legislature and will help us get more
quickly to a standard schedule for code
updates not to mention the ability to
deal with other related issues in a more
orderly manner we look forward to
working closely with this committee once
it's formed
this bill also provides a six-month
grace period previously
discussed
where the current or the updated code
may be used different language which
amends a different rsa section but to
the same effect is presented in hb 1681.
i recommend as previously uh recommended
that the hp 1681 language be used
in an effective
take it out of this bill as it has more
precise language it's not only longer it
gets to the point more accurately and
has been agreed upon by several of the
groups having interest that are
represented on on our board
uh
my written testimony which you i'm adam
chair you have a copy of gets to the
differences but that may not be uh
germaine at this point thank you for
this consideration and uh take any
questions
representative schmidt
i do have any commentary with regard to
the fire marshal's recommendation to
remove lines 23-29
yeah that gets to the point i agree
fully that's one way to deal with it
it's probably the best way thank you the
language in 1681 is our preferred
language so thank you very much thank
you
see no further questions thank you
are there any other members of the
public that wish to testify
seeing none i will close the public
hearing on house bill 398.
all right i
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
460 and
call senator reagan
good morning madam chair and members of
the executive departments and
administration committee i'm senator
john reagan from senate district 17 the
heart of new hampshire and i bring to
you today senate bill 460
which deals with the joint committee on
employee classification
i don't know how much
you want to know about that committee
but we have two types of employees in
new hampshire we have classified and
unclassified
the classified positions are looked at
as the sell rate employees
and the unclassified as the hourly
employees
yes
classified yeah
so classified as the more the hourly
employees
yeah
so
we have a we have a committee called the
joint committee unemployed
classification
and the department of administrative
services
when a
department head requested a
title change
or a
paid change
fills out a very lengthy application
and they bring it to the joint committee
on employee classification
who then
approves the application which is then
forwarded to the corn ferry hay group of
san francisco california
and what the
what the hay group does is compares that
job
with similar jobs throughout the united
states and
seeks to
justify or not justify the request for
the change in title or the increase in
salary
we have
recently
the former commissioner of health and
human services who found that health and
human services
were
titling people
at the
seeking a certain pay grade
and disregarding the titles
so
hence we have this bill with a laundry
list of job titles that are
just
dismissed and reinstated
and
that's why
this is an unprecedent unprecedented
number
of job title changes
so
when the recommendations come back from
the hay group
the committee meets and approves the
recommendations which are sent to the
fiscal committee
and that's how
the
unclassified people
get
changes and pay grades
and that's what we bring to you today
this was the latest effort by the joint
committee on employee classification
for these employees
here enlisted
so that these actually can be done
it requires an act of the legislature
so we put it into bill form
and bring it to you today
into the
house in the senate for approval
thank you senator we answer questions
sure representative schuett and then
grota
thank you this is actually more question
for the chair
have we seen an updated fiscal note on
this bill i see that
the statement at the time of
introduction was that
they did not have
information
i checked just one of the
um
representative grow to ask her question
while i look that up okay
thank you senator reagan um so if i
understand what you just said to us
the first
nine lines of the bill
are titles that are no longer
being used
and therefore we're going to delete
those yes and then the rest of the bill
are
departments
both of them the department is on the
left-hand side and the titles are on the
right-hand side and these are the ones
that we are now using
is that correct yes okay thank
you
there's no note that this bill has a new
fiscal note
and i would expect
if i understood senator reagan correctly
these are the same people doing the same
job we're just rationalizing the titles
the titles and the pay grades and the
pay grades yes so
are people getting major raises because
of this
within the reasonable judgment of the
hay group
that they are
in line with their peers and other
agencies okay that they
are earning that rate of pay
i see but for example on line five
there's a glenn cliff home administrator
salary grade ff
and down on line
29 there's the
executive director of the glenn glenkiff
of home which i presume is the same
person or the same job
at grade hh
okay
just for one
may be the same person
okay
and 428 yes the assistant commissioner
of the insurance department and also on
line seven the insurance department
general counsel is
line 27 and it's going up from ff to gg
so
uh we don't have a fiscal note
minimum chair
yes i'm over here yes my understanding
is that
and maybe senator
reagan can can confirm that my
understanding is that
from line 12 down these positions
already exist and these people are
already are exist at that grade level
and the people that are in line from
line three to line nine
don't exist so it i think the
my understanding is that
these people are already performing
these jobs at that pay grade so there
wouldn't have there wouldn't be a fiscal
note
and maybe that's probably not what
should be happening
okay if someone from the jcec could
explain what happens to these people
or i mean
the title is one
the trouble is that the titles and pay
grades are given in statute
so i madam chair if i might so i think i
think what we ought to
do is consult with uh the
commissioner of das
charlie arlinghaus who is the
person who actually administers the
situation the jcec is an executive board
several of the members are here today
senator reagan is the chair
senator and alessandro was the second
senator second senate member
on the jcec and representative scitec
and i are two of the three house members
but
some of these questions need to have the
administ need to have the commissioner
or
deputy commissioner joe bouchard here to
give us uh no so i think some of the
assumptions here are perhaps uh you know
incorrect uh and and we need to have
somebody
you know who can corroborate the actual
state of affairs before we
get into hypothesizing too much because
i think we're getting off track
thank you representative schmidt i tend
to agree with you that we're
hypothesizing in absence of the facts i
will try to get rep
the commissioner arlington or his deputy
here to explain what this is doing
before we we take a vote on it
are there any other questions for
senator reagan
okay seeing none thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 460.
okay
that's a good idea
we are i think i will i will recess this
until 1pm
and invite commissioner arlinghaus or or
his staff to join us at that well make
it
1 15.
so back in the old days when pam
smarling was still uh
the brains of the committee uh and but
most specifically not being uh sarcastic
here
when she was the staffer for the jcec
she handled all these details
in conjunction with commissioner
arlinghaus
deputy commissioner bushard and so forth
and other members of the high-level
high-level members of the jcc sorry the
das
um and now that she is retired uh we we
have to
you know yes yet another authority take
a while before we recover from that uh
change for sure all right so we're
recessed on
senate bill 460
and we have a few minutes before
the next hearing which is at 11 30.
yes rep representative fellows
okay i will invite the commissioner over
i'm going to right now okay
all right
we will resume at
this hearing at 1 15 and
at 11 30 we will have a different
uh
back
i'm opening the hearing on senate bill
356 and calling senator delasandra
thank you madam chair
for the record
i'm senator lou d'alessandro i represent
district 20 manchester awards 3 4 10 11
in the town of goffstown
i come before you as the prime sponsor
of senate bill 356.
this bill was asked for by the
department of environment
administrative services
as
a way to contain
medical costs
i'm here today to to introduce senate
bill 356 relative to medical benefits
payments by state retirees
this this is a bill to amend the
administrative billing process as
outlined in the application sections of
rsa
21-i colon 30 and rsa 100-a colon54
for state retirees and other eligible
members of the state retirement health
benefit plan
effective on january 1 2019 the
department of administrative services
das transitioned all medicare retirees
from the previously self-funded medicaid
supplemental plan to a fully insured
group medicaid advantage plan
by doing so the state capitalized on
additional federal funding and decreased
the premium costs charged to both state
and medicare eligible retirees
the intention of senate bill 356 is to
update the premium billing and
collections process
to ensure compliance with current
medicaid laws which will help sustain
the savings available to the state
through the fully insured plan
this bill is at a request of the
department of environment of
administrative services
and they're here to provide you with
additional information and to answer
your your questions uh cassie cane is
here
and joyce pittman is here and both
should be commended for the work that
they have done to control costs
and when i chair the finance committee
on the senate side we looked at the cost
for retirees health benefits and you all
know
how
how high they are
both of these people have done yeoman
work and controlling costs and given
better giving better service to the
retirees
this bill does a number of things let me
i'm i'm not the expert cassie's here and
joyce joyce is here and
they have embellished the process i can
say that
without without question
and uh uh they're wonderful to work with
and great people but the bill amends the
administrative building process outlined
in rsa
21-i colon 30 and rsa 100
dash a 50 colon 54 for state retirees
and other eligible members of the state
retirement health benefit plan
medicare retirees were transferred from
the previously self-funded medicaid
supplemental plan to a fully insured
group medicaid advantage plan effective
july january 1st 2019. uh senator yes
i don't like to disagree with you but
you keep saying medicaid and i believe
medicare is the operative program you're
right you're right thank you thank you
so much for that correction
i appreciate that
i want the committee to get confused
right well
i'm sorry i could confuse you i think so
i apologize for that i'm mortal
thank you
uh this chan
this change allowed the state to
capitalize on additional federal funding
and decrease the premium costs for both
state
and medicare eligible retirees this bill
intends to update the premium billing
and collection process as was requested
by the department and cassie kane was
instrumental in assisting with
this situation and as i say both both
members of admin services are here
this does good things for the state and
does good good things for the retirees
which indeed is is important and i think
the key issue is it decreased the cost
from 171 million
to 130 million in 2223 from 1819 to 2223
and that's a fairly significant
reduction in cost
and
the decreased budget can be attributed
to successful procurement efforts and
contract management combined with
maximizing federal subsidies on the
medicare plan
uh with that uh madam chair there aren't
many questions that i can answer about
this other than to say
it's a good thing
it's it's a benefit to our retirees and
it's a it's a real kudo to our state
employees who do such a great job
in fulfilling their job responsibilities
and that's to take care of
the needs of our state and to deliver
results in the most efficient and
effective manner so with that madam
chair i'll uh i'll retire i'll try to
address any questions that you might
have but
the two employees are here they are
experts in the area and they've done all
the work
okay
if they've done the work i think we
should ask them because
they'll probably be able to explain in
more detail thank you senator you're
very welcome
ms keene and miss pittman
good morning we have written testimony
we'll hand out
good morning my name is cassie keane i'm
the
deputy commissioner of the department of
administrative services and i'm here
with joyce pittman who serves as the
director
of our division of risk and benefits
and joyce is directly in charge of
administering the employee and retiree
health benefit plan and we're here today
to ask for some amendments to existing
law to help us make
our administration of the plan both more
efficient in terms of
in terms of effort and the money we
spend to administer the plan but also
to help us align state law so that we
can be in compliance with medicare law
so
i'm going to just briefly talk about
what we've been able to accomplish in
the retiree health benefit plan and then
i'm going to
ask joyce to share the details of the
bill with you
but
some of you may have been here back in
2015-2016 when we began a couple of
years of a rough ride with the retiree
health benefit budget
and that was both i think a period of
time where funding was constrained and
um and retiree numbers enrollments were
rising
and we went through a period of time
where the budget
didn't get funded to meet the needs of
the retiree health benefit projected
costs and then and then we had an
explosion
in
prescription drug costs and it began us
a series of years where we did whatever
we could to help save money
and
medicare has been a big part of that
picture and it's a if you look at the
chart in front of you i'm going to help
you understand why how we've been able
to achieve these savings
but just to let you know we have on the
prescription drugs side leverage
medicare funding to help control to the
best degree we are able prescription
drugs for our medicare retirees and then
beginning in 2019 i believe it was we
moved our
self-funded retiree health benefits for
medical benefits from
completely self-funded to a fully
insured medicare plan what that did was
bring in medicare funding federal
funding to help decrease the cost to the
state and also to our retirees part of
the solutions over the years with
how are we going to meet this deficit
that we did have in our retiree health
benefit plan
included retirees paying more toward the
cost of care so that we have
non-medicare retirees who pay 20 percent
of the cost of the monthly premium and
now certain retirees who
who are born 1149 and later
um contribute to
of the non-medicare premium
and
so we we moved our retirees from this
self-funded plan into a medicare part c
plan
and we were able to bring in federal
funds
now what this means is that our plan
administration has to comply with
medicare regulations and joyce is going
to tell you a little bit more about what
that means and why we're asking for a
change in the law
yes
so
senate bill 356 really focuses in on two
different areas one is pertaining to the
cms laws as written
we are not permitted to do any kind of
retroactive enrollment or disenrollment
or terminations on our plan the way the
current legislation is written
it says that our retirees can
basically get reinstated in the health
plan up to six months after
due to non-payment so we allow them a
six-month gap of not paying for their
benefits in our law today and then if
they decide to pay and make up the
difference for that six-month gap we'll
continue their benefits and um cms says
you cannot do that
so um and we haven't been doing that
because we by law cannot if we want to
when i say law i mean federal law
if we want to maintain those federal
subsidies that cassie was just referring
to that have enabled us to control our
costs to our retiree health benefit plan
we have to comply with that federal law
where that causes confusion is our
retirees are reading the state law and
they're saying well what do you mean i
can do this but we're trying to explain
to them well the federal law says you
cannot so we're trying to remove that
i'll say confusion for our retirees
because i don't think anyone wants us to
jeopardize that federal
uh subsidy coming in for our for our
retirees to benefit from that savings as
well as our our budget
um so that's the big change as far as
the cms um area the paragraph line
um
that yeah that's basically that's the
first section of the bill the second
section is pertaining to
i'm going to call it unnecessary costs
where we're required to provide
a 10-day notice period for when retirees
are
paying for their monthly premium
and then we are required to send them a
mail a letter certified
to them at seven dollars per letter
to avoid that termination
and what we've learned through over the
past couple years is our retirees are
using that 10-day grace period
as when their bills are due so they're
actually working with your banks to set
up an automatic payment
in the 10-day window which is great for
them because they can set it and forget
it but it's bad for us because the law
requires us to send them a certified
mail
telling them that they need to pay us
um to avoid that termination and we get
regular calls saying stop sending me
these certified letters you're just
wasting the state's money i already have
it all set up
so we've been working with our retirees
and we have another
vendor that we're working with for
retiree billing and collections where
we've actually gotten retirees to
correct that automatic bill pay so now
they're good they're in that window
where they're paying their bills on time
so we're not in uh
i gotcha we're going to terminate your
benefit business we actually want our
retirees to maintain their benefits and
we work with them to do so but we're
trying to avoid an unnecessary cost
by sending those
expensive notices to people who had
every intention to pay their bills
anyway
um so that's really what these
two sections of the bill are trying to
address is elimination of unnecessary
spending and also compliance with the
cms laws at the federal level
thank you very much i'm sure are there
any questions
on this procedure or this bill
representative lucas and then shut
okay thank you um
so you mentioned there are a number of
things that were done to save money
which is great i'm just wondering um
how much are we getting from the federal
government to support this program how
much of those savings are from uh the
federal contribution
so from the
medicare advantage side of the business
so the federal subsidies are coming in
they're actually going to aetna
and
aetna in turn is charging us a zero per
member per month premium contribution
for our retirees to be on that aetna
plan
just to give you an idea that xero is
locked in for 2021 22 and 23.
buy our contract
prior to that we were paying about a
hundred and ten dollars per month per
retiree to be on the previous medicare
advantage plan in 2020.
just to give you an idea there yep thank
you sure
representative
you madam chair um
hi
miss pittman and keane know you well
um you did not address section three of
the bill
and i'm curious
i know that
i introduced in fact house bill 130 last
term
because there was a question between
das and
the retirement system billing
retirees for their additional costs
and i'm curious
how if this resolves that
i understand that
there was concern on behalf of the
retirement system
that it put them in jeopardy for some
kind of regulation with the irs
so i'm curious
how that got resolved so so this bill
doesn't
[Music]
relate at all to the issue around
the nhrs withholding the premium from
certain retirement payments two separate
issues entirely and
paragraph three is about our ability to
comply with medicare law and joyce can
talk to you this is similar to what i
was saying before on the retroactive
enrollment and so the um
what medicare tells us we have to do is
we have to proactively enroll people so
if people do get terminated for
non-payment we are not able to
retroactively enroll them we have to
have them actually fill out new forms
um so we want to make it clear to our
retirees that if you allow your plan to
terminate due to non-payment it's not
just flipping the switch and turning you
back on you actually have to re-enroll
in order to go forward back on our it's
all prospective with medicare
so this section just
refers to the re-enrollment process
thank you
representative fellows
thank you madam chair so
the people that are affected by i'm
talking about
you know the the part that's like
three quarters of the way down the first
page here
are those all
people who
are getting a retirement
benefit
but their benefit
is not enough money to cover what you
have to withhold or is there anybody
else that is affected by this so this
pertains to so we do have the largest
number of our retirees who are required
to pay actually pay through an automatic
deduction from their new hampshire
retirement
pension payment so this does not apply
to them because it's happening
automatically for them
but if there is ever
for the retirees who actually have to
make a physical payment
this is who it applies to so to your
point is if their their pension check
isn't great enough to withhold the
contribution from it then we would build
them this applies to them it also
applies to
what representative stewart was
referring to is
a different bill that we're in a
different
area we are charging about 640 of our
retirees outside of the new hampshire
retirement system due to
an ongoing conversation that das is
having with new hampshire retirement
on how the uh
the
law is currently being interpreted
around that medical subsidy
so
that second group that you're talking
about are those people who
worked for the state and when they
retired they maybe they took all their
money out in cash
no
so if you take all of your money out in
cash and you're no longer getting a
monthly pension payment you're not
eligible for our retiree health benefits
so this is only for people who are
getting a monthly pension benefit on an
ongoing basis is that what your question
is asking yes that's what my first
question was and follow up
yeah so i'm not understanding because
you told me there were two groups so you
told me there were some that that you
were taking
taking the money tried to take the money
out of their retirement but it wasn't
enough to cover the help and what was
the second group so there's there are
two
we're actually talking about three
groups if i understood you so there's
the group that paid they get a monthly
pension check from the new hampshire
retirement system and they're eligible
for health insurance
new hampshire retirement takes a
deduction out of their monthly pension
check
and sends that to us for their monthly
payment that's group number one group
number two is people who don't have
enough money in that monthly pension
check to cover the cost of their health
insurance so we the department of
administrative services is required to
bill them outside of the new hampshire
retirement system pension payment
so it's they're still eligible for a
monthly pension check from nhrs which
they still receive but it doesn't take
the deduction for the health benefits is
not withheld so they're still required
by law to pay it so we have to invoice
them outside of the retirement system
the group three that i think i may
introduce but you weren't asking about
was the people who took a lump sum
payment from their pension when they
left state service and they are 100
percent done with the state of new
hampshire in terms of receiving pension
were you referring to those people
or
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
figure out who
is affected by this
because my next question was going to be
your follow-up representative fellows
yes thank you just a little one why why
are you billing them once a month
instead of like quarterly
instead it's actually how it's outlined
in the law but it's a lot easier for
them right now when we look at our
medicare retirees we're seeing twenty
dollars it feels like an
inconsequential amount to some it's a
lot to others um they may if they choose
pay in advance so if it's more
convenient for them to pay we have some
retirees that pay for the entire year in
advance
they're welcome to do that but we found
that it's more manageable for them on a
monthly basis to do it once a month just
like they get their monthly pension
check you get a monthly pension check at
the end of every month there's a check
sent to our retirees so we withhold once
with that check
thank you i have a question
you said that you have a contract with
aetna for a zero per month
premium so why are you billing people to
cover zero sure good question i was
waiting for that one
that is actually so remember we also
have prescription drug benefits so don't
forget about those so the zero front
does not include drugs correct that is
100 medical only so anything you get for
your medical services is through aetna
and your prescription drug is still
through
the prescription drug benefit is through
express scripts also a medicare
sponsored plan subject to the same rules
we have to comply with them as well
because i was wondering because that's
that seemed like an extraordinarily good
deal and i can't see why you would need
to
deduct zero every month and then bill
them for it but if there's a separate
charge for the drug coverage
thank you that makes a little more sense
any other questions
okay thank you very much i think you've
covered that
and i'd like to call mr roy schweiker
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee i'm roy schweiker from concord
and
i did not take a position on this
particular bill i don't know enough
about it i assume
those people have explained it carefully
but i'd like to mention a germain
amendment which will save the state
money improve conditions for retirees
and
help new hampshire businesses
as they've explained to you
there are separate
contracts and policies for the drug
benefit
and the
medicare part two benefit
and right now
retirees are required to accept both or
neither
they cannot choose one or the other
and this has been a concern of retirees
in the past
one person at a
meeting said well when i have adequate
health coverage from my husband's job
but i'd like the drug benefit
and
my case and those of other people is
different that we feel the drug benefit
is
terrible and we'd rather choose our own
there's a highly so
large number of competitive drug
benefits available
through medicare
that we could get on our own but you're
only allowed to have one
so because we're retired to take the one
from the state
we cannot
choose our own even if we do not accept
the state subsidy
so if you would add a third thing to
this bill
that retirees are allowed to choose
either or both of the two separately
that would save the state money from
retirees that didn't choose
one or the other
it would uh make things better for
retirees who could get themselves a
better plan
for less money than they're paying now
even for more money than they're paying
now the one that suits their needs and
one of my chief gripes about it is
that essentially you're required to buy
your thing from a mail order pharmacy
i don't have a secure mailbox
and while the drugs i'm getting are not
anything that a drug addict would want
they don't know that if they can steal
them
so i may wind up without drugs not
knowing they're missing
and ultimately you know what do i do
it's a pain
whereas if we allowed people to choose
their own drug plan then they could
choose a drug plan that gave a
reasonable co-pay to a new
hampshire-based business
i know someone that has a drug plan
through walmart that their typical
payment for a month's supply of drugs is
like 50 cents
whereas once again that's a problem with
this
one of the ways that in fact the state
has saved money on the prescription drug
plan is
the minimum charge for a generic drug
used to be a dollar it's now ten dollars
you know that's nine dollars that's a
900 increase well obviously that's one
way to keep costs down
but you know it's a hassle for those of
us who are paying it and why we don't
see this drug plan that the state has
got for us is being particularly useful
and
at the last hearing someone said oh yes
you can get them at a local pharmacy so
i brought the sheep today yes
i can get a three-month supply for ten
dollars mail order
but it cost me ten dollars for a one
month supply at a pharmacy so i'm paying
triple as much to buy it locally and
apparently i can only get it one month
at a time so i've got to go in every
month wasting gas instead of picking up
a three-month supply whereas if i was
able to choose one of the many available
drug plans then
i would be able to have a better system
for myself would save the state money
because they're not paying the 80 of my
drug subsidy i'd be helping new
hampshire businesses
so
and once again last time i said maybe
the state should
you know take a random sample of you
know plan participants without their
names and run the drugs through you know
different alternative plans to see
whether the one they chose is
you know most beneficial to retirees
well they didn't do that of course
and
if they try and tell you they can't
split the twos up separately i think
it's really because they're afraid
they'd lose so many customers from the
drug side of the thing that it would
show how bad their plan is
so no that's what i have to say thank
you
thank you for your testimony yes working
on pearson thank you um i appreciate the
concept that you're bringing forward
truly
what you're asking would be would work
fantastically to be filed next year
because it would have to be studied that
that's a change that is
is substantial
i think it has merit but i it would
definitely be something that we would
it would be extraordinarily difficult to
tack on as an amendment to to something
that that's such a substantive pop
change in operation
and and
so i i would suggest that you find
someone
to file this this piece of legislation
this fall for next year
is that a question
no that's just a little bit of advice on
the process
well i i don't understand why this is
such a major change all you're doing is
some people would get a bill for one
amount
some people would get a bill for the
other month which apparently actually is
zero
so it just means that some people would
get a bill and others wouldn't
i don't see that as a substantial change
at all i see it as a simple change that
would help retirees help businesses in
the state and save the state money
thank you for your suggestion we'll take
it under advisement
and thank you for your testimony are
there any any actual questions
represents
like us
represents did you have a question nope
okay thank you they're just twitching
thank you again for your testimony
is there any other member of the public
that wishes to testify on senate bill
all right seeing none i'll close the
public hearing
and we will be
resuming the hearing on
senate bill 460 at 1 15.
hey
uh
we're i'm resuming the hearing on
senate bill
and i have commissioner arlinghaus here
to explain to us what's going on with it
that was fast hi i'm charlie arlinghaus
i'm the commissioner of administrative
services and i'm going to do my best to
explain to you what's going on
every every year or two years there is a
clean up bill to
codify the actions of the joint
committee on employee classification
that committee evaluates all
unclassified positions has a number of
other
uh
smaller duties that they don't often
exercise but the biggest thing they do
is they look at all of the unclassified
positions
the classified positions are
administered by the division of
personnel
and reclassification decisions etc an
ongoing thing that's happening is the
department of health and human services
had for
quite some years with their their older
positions which are referred to
as terry morton positions um
had been putting people in them without
regard to what they did
and uh and so a lot of changes were made
where you would have somebody who was a
dentist who was actually the
functionally the chief information
technology officer they just tried to
match the salary with the person
the legislature
made them go back and take all of those
positions which i believe is about 80
and they are one by one by one
um having them be actively codified so
that the position questionnaire on
record has been evaluated like all
others and matches so every time you see
one of these bills you'll see a handful
of those there are something like six of
those in this bill
where they take somebody and they and
they make the title match occasionally
the title does match but occasionally
somebody was
serving in a role and that's not
actually what they did so these are now
fully
classified according to the
evaluation of a group called corn fairy
hay which is a national classification
group with which we have a contract so
that's one subset of them
that occasionally happens with other
positions assistant commissioner of
insurance is like that
the assistant commissioner insurance
position was classified quite some time
ago
and their duties
aren't what they were then so you have
that um that commission look at it jcec
ratifies that there are a number of
other positions a bunch of which happen
to be mine
where we took positions at senior
leadership positions that had been
classified
and they are now unclassified when you
do that you have to have those positions
evaluated as well
and what this bill does is simply
codify the result of those decisions
where
a questionnaire is filled out
it is sent to corn fairy slash hay group
to the two groups merged um to evaluate
it according to the uh their proprietary
evaluation software
like like a classification project it
then comes back as presented to the
joint committee the joint committee
ratifies it it then becomes effective
but the committee is required to do a
cleanup bill to put it into the statute
that's what's happening globally i can
talk about specific positions if you
need maybe
i hope so does this
this includes the salary ranges for the
positions in your department the deputy
director and so forth we made
unclassified last year
yes
so the so the letter grade to the left
if you look at the bill and you see gg
department of administrative services
deputy director division of financial
data management
gg is a grade is a is a is a labor grade
a salary range with seven steps in it in
the classified system they're numbered
one through 35. i don't think we have
any ones anymore but and in the
unclassified system they're lettered a
through
[Music]
actually aaa through something
it's two letters not one because in
2010ish
all the positions in state government
were redone and to save confusion they
did a double letter instead of a single
letter
or to create confusion either yes
representative allegro
excuse me i've been sitting here so
quiet today that i forgot
um
maybe this has been mentioned and uh i
was distracted but what's the difference
in pay range
between say a gg and an hh
roughly it's a good question i'm going
to say that
i'm going to say about 5
no that's too high it's going to be more
like four percent i can look them up the
the grades are published they're
actually on our website if you go to uh
das website and human resources is an
unclassified salary schedule if you get
to job classification but
um but i'm gonna guess that it's about
um
about four thousand dollars on a on a
maximum pay of a hundred and
six hundred and eight in in that range i
can i can send the committee if you want
the unclassified schedule no that
doesn't thank you
representative blackist and then scitec
thank you um
i don't know if you can answer this
question but looking here not only are
the titles changed
um but
the the salary uh range letters have
changed for a number of these
and you know they're they're higher so
presumably
some people are going to be getting paid
more
um and given that i am disturbed that
there's not a fiscal note on this i mean
they must know how many of these
employees there are in these positions
and uh and what the increase is and all
that so do you is there some reason you
know of why there's no fiscal note or
well what would typically happen in a
situation like this is as as a result of
this change your budget does not change
it it you're gonna have to ask you might
have to ask for something different in
the next salary in the next budget but
you're expected to absorb the costs
within your existing budget so you're
not granted additional budget budget
authority for this so in terms of the
overall state spend
the state spend isn't changing so let's
just say you have a salary line where
your class
typically class 11 or 12 is where these
are budgeted let's say your class 11
line is uh you know 262 thousand dollars
and uh and this happens
um you're still limited to that 262 000
and that uh so that doesn't change in
terms of a fiscal impact from a
budgetary standpoint um you have no
additional spending authority
thank you
i take it that the
the ranges overlap a bit so that
typically the
let's say for example so seven steps
right in the unclassified range step six
of uh of a of a lower grade is the same
as step five of a higher grade
because of oddities over time the
unclassified ranges are a little bit
weirder
that that's almost perfectly done in the
classified system where you move
diagonally along a grid and you can just
go bang the same number um the
unclassified system odd things happen
where there are slight anomalies but
generally speaking a five is the same as
six of the one one away from it
so there's a lot of overlap thank you
represent follow-up
thank you so um
it might i mean i don't know how raises
are handled but uh so this might provide
some mild pressure for increases in the
future but it won't do anything in the
short term i guess
i mean if somebody's in at a lower
i know i knew how the salaries worked at
places i work but uh you know if you're
the lower end of the salary range
assuming you're doing well you're more
likely to get more of a raise than if
you're towards the higher end of your
salary range and i don't know if that's
true that's not true in state government
so in state government uh the the in the
collective bargaining the because it's a
unionized system right the collective
bargaining agreement will will um if one
is signed will typically have an
adjustment
often referred to as a cost of living
adjustment because it tends to track
what that doesn't have to
um but it but it tends to
your your raises i have no discretion in
granting good performers about uh more
money
that's not part of the state system
merit is although it's called a merit
system
performance bonuses etc are not part of
it um
you're moving from one step to another
you're in step five moving to a step six
is governed by um statute or the cba and
it's and it's based on longevity
all right thank you
representative
and representative pearson thank you
madam chair
as with the private sector
and with the current
human resource
picture that is painted in what is
extraordinarily competitive market in
new hampshire has the inability to
fill some of these positions been
factored into the classification rate
change
no
technically the classification system
both in the unclassified and classified
range is based on is based on job
content and it is specifically forbidden
to use um
in in this in this provision it's
forbidden to use um
uh recruitment difficulties for that
which is why you end up seeing things
for example nursing positions um tend to
have an enhanced pay their their job
content determines a number but you
can't hire people at that number so
there are there are a couple of
extraordinary measures that you can do
that the one exception to that in the
unclassified system that's very rarely
done but it is done on occasion the the
most the easy easiest to explain uh
version is medical examiners
if you do if you evaluate a medical
examiner on job content they they come
in at a fairly high number
but not that high because it's
apparently not
i don't want to know how to phrase this
exactly it's not that complicated
but there just aren't that many people
who want to cut up dead bodies for a
living
so uh you can't hire somebody at the
number that comes up with so there's a
there is a range established in in
statute it's a section of 941
for that which is frankly double roughly
what they were evaluated at they make a
great deal more than say the governor
the one if you look at the bottom of the
bill
uh subparagraph three
salary adjustment for recruitment and
retention
um
this is this is done the unclassified i
think there are seven positions where
this has been done
and this one the deputy director of
accounting services is the deputy
comptroller
and uh the comptroller salary is off
grid
and the deputy comptroller salary is
grid by a percentage
so she has a range outside she currently
sherry rockburn has a range outside of
that grid which actually in this case
approximates
somewhere between a g and an h
okay i can i can appreciate the fact
that the medical examiner's patients
rarely complain
but the
the fact is is that we have some
positions in government that we just are
not getting filled yes so if
if there if we're prohibited
from changing the grade on these
to
balance or match market conditions
is the state suffering
in the sense that we have
fairly important functions here that are
just not being performed because our
hands are tied with the with the system
that i if i'm understanding you collect
really can't be modified to deal with
market conditions in in this part of the
process they can't be modified there are
a couple of methods for modifying them
and i mentioned nurses because they're
the most prominent example where nursing
salaries are enhanced by sometimes 45
because that's that's what nurses get
and so there are increasingly there's
something like a thousand positions in
state government where where they have
an enhanced range it's not based on job
content but there's an enhancement
um in the unclassified ranks it it's
many fewer again six or seven
um
in um
the system is old
old-fashioned and uh awkward
and we are
currently doing a lot there's a lot of
work being done through the division of
personnel to look at the classification
system how it's organized how it's
arranged
and and what what we can do with it to
make it more modern it was established
in our case it's you know most of it
goes back to president garfield
um it was established in our case as a
result of social security amendments in
1939 governor murphy
and um at the time there's a vision of
the system that's functionally clerks
and supervisors right that everybody's
cat everybody's job is either a clerk or
a supervisor and so it's very simple to
classify it's just not how the world
works frankly it wasn't then and
certainly isn't now
and we're in the process of you have to
evaluate somebody with significant
computer skills um against somebody
who's a purchasing agent and their jobs
aren't related or comparable that well
um but we do it so we're looking at
changing the system
i i think one of those things is going
to have to be one of the factors we do a
factor analysis
is going to have to be some sort of a
sort of a market factor you have to be
careful about doing that because the
system is i mean there are a couple
things one is it is
it is a is controlled by collective
bargaining agreements and you have to
take that into consideration always in
addition to that it's the government
it's not it's not a private company
where people can uh people can make
decisions and there are responsibilities
to the taxpayers um in terms of
transparency and in terms of equity and
in terms of ensuring that people don't
benefit from favoritism
that require
a more complicated structure but are we
suffering i would say we're suffering in
the same way that everybody else is our
our vacancy rates are higher than
historical
averages which tend to be
9 to 11 and we're we're at about 17
um
but they're coming down a little bit and
um hiring is a lot of work but if you
stick your nose to the grindstone you
can hire
i interviewed two i
interview and i do typically do final
interviews um with two to three people a
week on average over the last uh
25 weeks so we're bringing people in
sometimes from other agencies don't tell
them but um
we're bringing people in
other representatives and then
thank you madam chair um just an aside
strange that you mentioned president
garfield as i recall he was
assassinated by a disappointed office
seeker
but seriously my my question is in line
with representative lake is from the
standpoint do you know why
they were unable to
give us a fiscal note on this i
i was able to i started looking at this
bill
and for example
if you look at rsa 99 or 94 colon 1
the rates for like the starting rate at
each grade is there
and i just looked at the assistant
commissioner for the insurance
department
the starting rate at ee is 68 000
and this would move him to a gg
which is 78 000
seems like it would be fairly simple to
rate the cause one's concern of
representative schuett is that there are
probably only one person in that
position and it probably matters a great
deal whether he's at step one or step
seven
well i'm still guessing and all of these
i imagine are very
it's not like you say you've got a labor
grade 27 clerk
because there's lots of them
there's one
in one of each and you'd
and they i'm not sure they'd be willing
to make a quick and dirty guess that
doesn't seem like their style i think
the other i think the other point on the
on the fiscal impact is again it's a
fiscal impact is a budgetary impact and
as with the reclassification in the
classified system you are expected to
absorb it in your budget this is not
this is not an attempt to get you
additional budget authority so in that
respect there's not a fiscal impact you
do not have to appropriate more money we
will not cut a warrant
of any sort on the basis of this piece
of legislation so typically like a if
there's a fiscal impact it's something
where or at the end of it when it passes
somebody goes over to the bureau of
accounts and we end up having a warrant
and they do the monthly summary of
warrant adjustments there's a warrant
um there's an adjustment to the
appropriations the appropriations unit
is involved in this particular case that
won't happen because you again you're
you're absorbing it within your budget
if there are adjustments to be made
they're both salary adjustment funds and
benefit adjustment funds but that's a
it's a separate process and there's not
an additional appropriation and i think
that's that's the real story i will note
about president garfield that in fact
that's exactly why
president arthur after he died passed
the civil service reform bill was
because he got killed by a disgruntled
office seeker
thank you for the history lesson
is there are there any other questions
for the commissioner
representative schmidt you're good okay
thank you
anyone else
all right well thank you for coming
making a special trip
need anything else i'm just across the
street right
okay
i will close the hearing on senate bill
460.
open the hearing on senate bill 397 and
call the prime sponsor
senator kahn
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record uh i'm jay kahn
state senator from keene representing
15 of 23 towns in cheshire county
it's a
pleasure to introduce this
bill
together with my colleague senator
carson
uh we teamed up to give you the largest
bill
uh of the session i think
what do you think yeah
what an
eighth of a pound maybe representative
in any case
these are two separate sections brought
together in the senate
because they both involve
compacts with other states
in the case of the original legislation
entering into an agreement for
interstate licensure and reciprocity
for counseling licensures
this
is a compact that requires a minimum of
10 states
before it is enacted
there are currently
seven states that have
entered into the compact
those seven states include maine
maryland
alabama mississippi
louisiana and
colorado
the
there are 15 other states
that are considering licensure
just as we are
so it's very likely during this
legislative
session of 2022
that
this the minimum number of states to
enact this compact will be achieved
for
new hampshire to enter into this
we we give up nothing in our current
licensing statute for counseling
all
existing statutes conditions need to be
met
in new hampshire
if a person wishes to be licensed in new
hampshire they'll pay the fee
they just won't go through as
much of a
review
because they are in another compact
state
which has agreed to live by the same
standards any kind of discipline
that
new hampshire
would exercise over a practicing
licensed person
would apply to a person who is in a
reciprocity state and has sought
licensure in new hampshire
so
the other thing i'd like to to point out
is that
other than maine
there is no other new england state
currently considering
entering into this in this year
that's good news for new hampshire
we all know
the mental health
counseling needs that there are in the
state they affect every region in the
state
we have people that are waiting
excessive periods of time
particularly if they are medicaid
payers
and
we need to solve this problem creatively
and so i think that the
department of
professional licensure and certification
has brought forth a
worthwhile
proposal that can begin to address those
workforce needs
there are endorsements that you should
have received from the american
psychology associate american counseling
association
and also the united states department of
defense
why would the department of defense
enter into this
debate in new hampshire
it's because
when their
military counseling personnel
are discharged from military service
they begin to consider what other states
they would wish to be licensed in or
practice in
so
the reciprocity agreement is an
important step for military personnel to
be able to
choose the state and
not have an excessive burden on them
to be re-licensed
in another state
and this is the new hampshire advantage
that comes from authorizing this compact
is that uh
i know this from
our
region 10
mental health
department
uh
it is that when
people
seek to be licensed we are not as quick
as other states
in that process
and
people have turned down jobs in new
hampshire because those processes are
faster in other states
this is an accelerator
this compact would accelerate those
licensing
from out-of-state
qualified people
into new hampshire
and give us a competitive advantage in
attracting people from other states who
are looking to relocate in new england
so
that's why this is before you uh and why
i believe the the senate gave uh such a
positive endorsement uh to this compact
and there are people there is a
representative from uh professional
licensure and certification present
uh to answer additional questions
but i'd be glad to hear what yours are
and maybe deflect them over to mr
shoemaker
i do have one question
i know that we don't just license mental
health counselors we've got social
workers
and psychologists and pastoral
psychotherapists the whole bit and
they're all very
jealously maintaining their distinctions
does this address that or just says
you're a counselor
it's a counselor
it is not for social work
it's only for mental health counselors
not any of the other worker mental
health workers that we license
uh it may
cover pastoral
counseling
but it is for the counseling statute
so it's for only one of the multiple
mental health
professions we license yes
thank you i'm glad to have that that
cleared up are there any other questions
representative pearson
thank you madam chair and thank you
senator for
keeping the paper mills in business
the
question that i have and this is
something that kind of holds true with a
lot of the compacts that we enter into
in the state of new hampshire
and you brought up uh discipline
so
and we've now you know there's no
uniform
continuity here between some of these
compacts if a provider in new hampshire
has a complainary problem in another
state
is that handled in new hampshire or is
it handled in the other state and then
vice versa if we have a provider that's
you know say from maryland
and there's a complaint registered in
new hampshire is that handled
in maryland
or new hampshire you see what i'm
getting at so does this does this cover
that
it does
and
mr shoemaker i but i
stand up if i get this wrong i believe
that the adjudication of that takes
place in the state in which the service
was provided
and the results are reported to the home
state correct
perfect thank you okay
represent black us
thank you
um if i understood you correctly you
said that
if there's somebody who's licensed in
another state is part of the compact and
we're part of the compact
they could come to new hampshire they
would still need to get a new hampshire
license but the procedure would be
abbreviated because they'd already met
some requirements is that correct yes
okay follow up or get into the actual
question
um i'm looking i was looking at the
telehealth section so that's a thing
where
somebody's still residing in another
state and they're going to be
have a client in new hampshire as i
understand it
do they have to in that case get a new
hampshire license as i read this i think
the answer is no but could you confirm
that
i don't think that this requires that i
think there are other
bills that are before the legislature
this year
that
if you are practicing
taking clients in this state you need to
be licensed in this state
we have
currently emergency and probationary
licensure
and that too is another bill before the
legislature to extend
probationary
licensure temp i'm sorry temporary
licensure
for another two years through
january of 2024.
so
there are a variety of vehicles for
an out-of-state practitioner to provide
telehealth services in the state of new
hampshire
um
follow-up
yeah i'm just wondering if someone else
here later can speak to this or if that
could be looked into because i'm looking
at
the section that uh adds 330 d6 compact
practice to uh
practice telehealth
and as i read it it says that they can
do it and they don't it doesn't say they
have to have a new hampshire license so
i'd like clarification at some point on
that good tell me again this section um
it
it's the section i don't know i don't
have the line number here but it's uh
it's it's at 330 d6
page seven
starting on line 32 compact privilege to
practice telehealth thank you
good
good thank you
it does say that uh on the next page the
licensee doing telehealth
shall adhere to the laws and regulations
of the remote state which says that if
our law says you have to have a license
they do
which is where we're heading i believe
other questions
thank you senator
thank you i'd like to call senator
carson
thank you very much madam chair
house members of edna
for the record my name is sharon carson
i have the pleasure of representing
senate district 14 comprising the towns
of londonderry hudson and auburn
and this morning this afternoon excuse
me i'd like to speak to you about senate
bill 397 but i
think i can answer representative
likus's question if that's okay with you
madam chair
please um we've had a number of bills
dealing with the issue of telehealth um
you'll find that there was a piece in
here there's also a piece in a bill
that's going to be going to hhs i
believe it's senate bill 430 so you
might want to take a look at that
we also had a bill last week
dealing with telehealth and one of the
things that we discovered was that
new hampshire in 2016 joined a medical
doctor's compact that recognizes the
license of doctors from other states
currently there are 31
states that are part of that compact
other states are have legislation
pending on that and what it does is it
recognizes the fact that they're a
doctor in good standing in their state
and it makes it very
easy for them to get a reciprocal
license here in new hampshire
there's also statutes dealing with
doc exempting doctors that are on the
border states surrounding us
for requirements for licensure and we
also put in an amendment
to fill that small hole that exists with
doctors that are not part of the the
states that are not a part of this other
compact that they're going to be able to
be get to get a reciprocal license here
in new hampshire if they're in good
standing in their state so i think
there's a number of different pieces of
legislation that's moving through the
legislature right now dealing with
telehealth okay thank you you're welcome
madam chair um what i'd like to do
is i have i i was asked to draw up an
amendment i had it drawn up
to present to the committee
for your consideration um is that okay
if i
what's this amendment about this
amendment deals with the section of the
compact if that i added to this bill
because i amended this bill
to add in another compact
um if you'd like i can speak to that
first
uh plea well
yes i think what other compact you think
i might be a little ahead of you
well
thank you madam chair um i was asked to
bring in an amendment to this compact
dealing with a different compact
that
that we are currently a part of it was a
compact that was first put together i
believe in 1965
and we've been a member of and it deals
with um children
uh most of the section that we were
really interested in was the placement
of children across state lines as you
all know we're dealing with the uh the
tragedy of finding a missing little girl
harmony montgomery
and
we do know now that she was placed here
in new hampshire without a home study
being done in fact there was no
communication that was between the state
of massachusetts and new hampshire about
this little girl
and we are we are all putting our
efforts forward to try to find her
and
when this issue started coming forward i
remembered that we had
a couple of bills dealing with this
issue but unfortunately because of the
pandemic they were either part of
omnibus bills that got killed or they
were just bills that were placed on the
table
and i'm referring to some of the
testimony that i had already given her
given on this issue one was senate bill
698 the other was senate bill 699 which
were filed in 2000 as a request of dhhs
and again this was brought forward
because of uh the harmony montgomery
clays
what my the section of the bill that i
amended this particular bill with
replaces the current language in rsa
170a and would not become effective
until 35 states have adopted the compact
if we choose to join the compact as one
of the original 35 states we'll have a
seat at the table which is as you know
is very very important as this
legislation goes through
this compact sets the framework when
working with other states to act
uniformly with the interstate placement
of children
and again our current compact is out of
date
which results in delays with the icpc
placements
so um there's going to be people from
the department that are here they're
going to be able to speak to this bill
but i was asked to bring in an amendment
that would put this particular part of
the concerning the placement of children
into law right away
i don't know
again how the committee might feel about
that i know it's not the way we usually
do things but i was asked to bring in
the amendment and so
um with the chair's
permission yes well if you're just
changing the effective date that's not a
big deal
well it's a little bit more than that
but
hopefully you folks can just think about
it and consider what you would like to
do whether you adopt the amendment or
not is up to you
um well i would like to have suggest
that it would have been possible for you
to take some bill you didn't like and
amended that to include this compact
because
the
interstate compact for the placement of
children
more properly belongs in a different
committee
i would agree that and that's why i
believe chairman rice here is from
children and family law
but
the issue came to edna as you know
because it is an interstate compact
and this was the only interstate compact
that we had so we amended that bill with
the kind concession of senator khan and
i would like to publicly thank him for
allowing us to do this with his bill
so what you basically have in front of
you are two two different compacts
same subject
same compact not same compacts but both
compacts with different subjects
do both these compacts have the clause
that says that their rules have the
force and effective law whether we pat
pass them or not
i can't speak to that madam chair i'm
not sure
representative lackas
thank you um
so as i understand it
this would um
repeal rsa 178 and replace it as i
understand you said we're part of a
compact now and have been since the 60s
so and then this new compact as i
understand it would take some number of
states to join it for it to become
go into effect
so what are the consequences of as i
understand it leaving an existing
compact and not joining another one as i
understand it until more states sign up
is or am i misunderstanding this
um thank you um
i believe that's what this amendment
addresses that if for some reason that
we decide we're not going to rejoin the
compact this language will be in statute
and will allow for the cross-state
communication um concerning the
placement of children
because there's no guarantee that we
would join the compact um even though
we're already a part of the existing
compact um it is a new compact and it's
updating
what's in place i mean the world is a
very very different place than it was in
so um but we want to be able to have
something in place
just in case this fails so quick
follow-up follow-up so is the old
compact going away in general or is
there some reason we have to leave it
before
if we choose to join the new one or
how's what's the coordination there
thank you for that a question
representative i believe someone from
the department will be able to explain
what the mechanics of this is going to
do okay thank you yes i also am
in the first part of 170a as
inserted by the spill it just says the
interstate compact for the placement of
children and it doesn't say which
version that applies to because if you
could read this it says well we've it's
already been enacted by more than 30 35
states
we're already there
and that would be the old version i hope
you fix that language in your amendment
um
we have that amendment so hopefully it's
fixed it came from the department
um but it's my understanding we we do
not have 35 states that have signed on
to it yet so but they signed on to the
original one yeah this does not specify
you know rev a or whatever okay
yes representative pearson thank you
madam chair in reference to the the 35
number
the new compact
the the enaction of that new compact the
threshold is 35 states or is that just
you're just referencing the prior
compact as far as the num
my understanding representative is it's
35 states
35 states have to sign on to it in order
for it to become effective unlike the
other one where it's 15.
i i'm not i think we'll let the expert
answer that the expert will be able to
answer that
can we get that question answered right
now rather than
he's the next one up if there are no
other questions for senator carson thank
you
are there any
seeing none thank you very much senator
joe schumacher
take the hot seat please
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
joe shoemaker i'm the director of the
division of licensing and board
administration at the office of
professional licensure
just to clarify um you know we are here
in support of senate bill 397
but really the original bill i cannot
speak to the compact that was just
brought up we're here in support of the
mental health counseling compact
just to clarify so certainly happy to
answer any questions
regarding that compact
in that case since we did have a hanging
question is there anyone who knows about
the approval of the compact for children
that can answer the question of how many
states have to approve it
is there anyone here who knows that
number
mr williams yes
that's um
president mcguire hi for the record um
i'm john williams i'm the director of
legislative affairs for the department
of health and services and my apologies
uh chairman uh if you could repeat the
question i'll do my best to answer it
the question
representative pearson your question
mike thank you madam chair my question
involved you know we in the original
bill we're looking at a compact that
involves a 15 state threshold
for it to kick in
this
particular
new part that involves the placement of
children what's the threshold for that
compact to kick in
so in the same way mr shamaker was
representing that he was here on behalf
of the office of professional licensure
certification for the first part of the
bill which dealt with sections one and
two respectfully i'm here on section
three the bill that deals with the
interstate
compact on child placement
you'll see in the bill itself under one
of the articles uh i believe it's
article 5 of the bill that deals with an
effective date it says there has to be
35 states that actually adopt
legislation to
accepting the compact before the compact
would take effect
and at current time the last i heard
from our subject matter experts we were
somewhere between 17 and 20 states and
we actually this is the third time
around with this very important piece of
legislation and the numbers uh creep up
a couple of states per per year
to address the other question until 35
states actually adopt legislation it's
very clear in the effective date and the
springing contingency that it would not
be effective here in new hampshire until
such time that 35 states adopted that
same um
same bill
follow-up
thank you so you can understand then the
the concern here of of exiting a compact
to enter into a new compact that has an
extraordinarily high
threshold here at 30 i mean 50 states i
mean 35 out of the 50s
is quite a high bar so are you
comfortable
because you guys are gonna have to deal
with this are you comfortable with
the language
that exists here
in reference to
the
contingent withdrawal of an existing
compact
based on the ability to enter into the
new compact is your office comfortable
with the way that is
in the event that we get to 33 and stop
um so uh i'm chairman mcguire in
addressing represent pearson's question
this
um compact was developed by a lot of
experts at a at a national level in
terms of creating a model they were the
ones that determined the uniformity of
how many states would have to come
aboard i think it's pretty close to what
i think would be a super majority of
states entering into it before that
compact would then become effective in
those respective states i think they did
that in contemplation for reciprocity
purposes that they wanted to make sure
there was a sufficient number of states
that would be able to speak to each
other through the same compact rather
than an outdated compact
if you do not pass the legislation what
you are left with is as senator carson
appropriately stated is a very outdated
law in terms of how our state interacts
with other states whether we're
receiving children here and having to
honor
whatever
protocols placements court orders what
not from another jurisdiction or the
reverse it really is important looking
prospectively to making sure that new
hampshire's laws are updated this is
just happens to be the process to which
this takes place and and it's the model
legislation that mandated the 35 states
you can make some adjustments in
compacts but typically you take them
pretty much wholesale unless they
otherwise directly you can take certain
pieces out this is not a piece that
we've been told that you could change
that's fantastic but did not answer my
question
i will do my best with a yes or no
the the question was
is your office comfortable
with the transition languages in here
that's extracting us out of an old
compact
and putting us into a new compact
in the way that is it
because the way i'm if i'm hearing this
right if this passes
we're out of the old one
we're not out
no
okay so then i guess that's that's where
we're i need a little bit of more
clarification then is to
it's a there sounds like there's a big
if then going on here in the sense that
we remain in the initial 1965 compact
up until the point of entering into the
new compact
yep
and it doesn't leave us in in a limbo of
exiting one but not another happens in a
magical nanosecond of time that's
measurable
thank you
uh representative fellows you have a
question
yes oh
is this for mr williams
so
so maybe let let me see if i'm
understanding this correctly
so section five of the bill which is on
the very last fit page has a contingency
and basically it says that
um
the section three
which is the language in the bill
of
of a compact
is not replaced
does not does not occur
until there are 35 states already signed
on to it
so my question is is that correct and
what might be a better substitute
um for
what's here in the bill
is
something we might see in an amendment
this is one where i would suggest you
may want to speak with the attorneys at
the office of state of services because
they could actually take the time
offline to explain to the nuances that
are involved with reading this
contingency but i will do my best with
this audience you have section five of
the bill that deals with the contingency
that says essentially what exactly what
you just said that sections three and
four of the act uh of this uh 2009
edition of the icpc shall take effect on
the date that the commissioner of the
department health and services certifies
the legislative services and secretary
of state that 35 compacting states
including new hampshire have enacted the
2009 edition of the icpc
if you go into section 3 of the bill
there's actually provision that mirrors
this as well that discusses the
springing contingency that you have to
have 35 states that adopt this before
such time that it would go into effect
here in new hampshire or any other state
that adopted it through legislation
that is the answer yes thank you um
well got a question yeah the
section five is on the last page page 37
and representative lucas you had a
question
um i think it's been uh answered the
only thing i'll say is if you look at
the amendment that was passed around it
also interacts with this
thank you
i yes you should have
if you didn't i believe
we will make sure you get them
i've got one
okay and represent mcguire if i could
comment just one item on the amendment
because i was a participant in the
drafting of this with um with um the
senate and uh working along with senator
carson but also with director joe ripson
because of the complexities that you see
with the springing contingency dates
built in here we had to be very careful
to making sure that we brought forward
the amendment that senator carson
provided to you
because of the fact
that section three of the bill goes into
effect only after 35 states adopted
there is a critical need for a portion
of the bill which is reflected in this
amendment to be uh to be enacted upon um
i believe what i'm trying to look for
upon its passage or 60 days i have to
read the language quickly but it needed
to be
more immediate rather than waiting for
other 35 states to come on board we need
to have this provision for the reasons
that were provided for child protection
reasons that senator carson so artfully
spoke about
okay thank you so we will consider that
senator carson some new words
i believe this bill is going to go to
subcommittee because it is
there's no way we can handle it at once
okay are there any other questions for
mr williams
thank you we will expect you at the
subcommittee
mr shoemaker if you if you care to
explain the first part
good afternoon again for the record joe
shoemaker director of licensing and
board administration at the office of
professional licensure and certification
i believe uh director courtney has
submitted testimony
i'll basically going to summarize that
this morning but to clarify we are here
or i'm here on behalf of oplc
to support the portions of this bill
related to the mental health counseling
compact
i believe you're all aware new hampshire
has a significant
behavioral health force health
workforce shortage which was exacerbated
during the pandemic
at the beginning of the state of
emergency in march of 2020
governor sununu issued an executive
order permitting the office
to issue licenses to health care workers
from out of state
at that point
new hampshire observed a massive
increase in the total number of licensed
behavioral health clinicians 63 percent
of psychologists 40 percent of marriage
and family therapists and 45 percent of
clinical mental health counselors
who were licensed during 2021 were doing
so under those emergency licenses
these statistics overwhelmingly
demonstrate that new hampshire must take
changes or make changes to licensure of
mental health professions to enable
greater licensed portability
senate bill 397 proposes to enact the
mental health counseling compact
as this committee is no doubt aware new
hampshire is a member of most
occupational licensing compacts
oplc has observed that compacts which
are agreement between states
significantly reduce the amount of time
it takes to become licensed
as was discussed earlier this compact
becomes effective once 10 states adopt
the compact
we understand that at least six states
have adopted the compact
and 15 additional states at this time
have legislation in place
are going forward at this time
so it is promising that this will pass
this year and the compact will be
enacted
given the behavioral health workforce
shortage oplc strongly supports the
provisions of senate bill 397 adopting
the mental health counseling compact
i'd be happy to answer any questions you
may have
thank you are there any questions
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question
we've had a number
of compact bills come before us
and most recently we withdrew from one
and we keep hearing when these bills
come forward once a number of states
reach this goal it will be an act
enacted
and
a number of these have gone on for a
number of years to get to that point
my question is once we get into these
compacts
it sets up for them to set the rules for
us not for us to set the rules for them
and
while we all
strive to be the first ones at the table
so we can set the rules
that may not be the case
and do you feel that we are giving up
too much by getting into these compacts
than what we should be
um because
once they're enacted
we're in it
unless we decide to get out like we did
with this last one
yes thank you for the question
representative goalie i certainly
understand your concern
our understanding although there's no
members of the board of mental health
here today that the board does support
this compact
they have reviewed the initial
requirements as you've noted the initial
requirements come in and are set to join
but the provision thereafter
every
board that's a member every state that's
a member has a seat at that table
and if when
any of those rules change by vote
majority vote of those states
we would need to abide by those
and the way we would need to back out of
the compact uh which is noted in here
would be to submit legislation to
withdraw
i can tell you as i mentioned earlier
i'm not aware of any major concerns with
the professional licensing compacts
that we
are a part of now it was mentioned
earlier we've had the the medicine
compact since 2016.
we have compacts with the allied health
boards
and several uh licensed reciprocity
agreements with national organizations
such as engineers architects accountants
and so forth
and i'm not aware of any major concerns
with the professional licensing compacts
we've been involved with today
other questions
okay thank you very much mr schumacher
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on senate bill 397
all right seeing none i will close the
public hearing
representative pearson it's this one's
your baby
and i feel like i just got triplets
i do have a request though madam chair
if we're going to do a subcommittee i'd
like a joint subcommittee with with
representative rice's committee as well
i think that that's
would be highly appropriate considering
the nature and topic of what's going on
this is more than just simply
um a procedural
re
um reconstruction i think this
definitely involves the policy portion
of what they do so i would ask that we
that we form a joint subcommittee with
her with her folks
i would agree provided she's okay with
that yes
representative first
and and then we can focus on the
interstate compact second so that my
committee members aren't sitting through
it sure
fair enough i you but probably more
would
that would be the sensible way to do it
all right
okay
let's see
that's
yes representative
i think so unless uh unless somebody
wants to
move into executive session we're done
for the day
okay your representative goalie
okay we're going into executive session
on senate bill 223
and representative goldie you have a
motion
thank you madam chair i move out to pass
on senate bill 223
is there a second
representative schmidt okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
i'll speak briefly i think this bill as
we heard from the fire marshal
takes away from an arbitrary figure of
the 200 when they put it into uh using
dormitory numbers to what it really is
as more of a rooming house and goes by
what is set as a national standard for
recovery houses at 50 square feet per
bedroom
so it makes it
uh consistent
okay representative schmidt do you have
a question
thank you ma'am try i just would say
that uh clearly the 200 square feet
figure that is currently
in effect
is completely unworkable and
unreasonable under this concept
and but 50 square feet is workable for
the purpose that
these recovery houses are being operated
when it's obvious you cannot have
multiple individuals rooming together
who are in recovery i think that's
running a risk that would be uh
extremely unwise
and so
we i think that we need to support this
bill thank you
okay
representative allegro yeah there seemed
to be some difficulty before
um defining what gross square feet is
and so i looked it up and it includes
outer wall to outer wall
so 50 square feet is actually an
overestimate and you can imagine if you
had six of these rooms on a corridor
you'd have to take away
some of that
space particularly if there was a wall
and and
the definition specifically includes
unused space dead space
so if you had a a gap somewhere you're
looking at less than 50 square feet i
was just fooling around
i don't want to call it an amendment but
with some other ways to look at this
um
and i haven't really organized my
thoughts very well but
uh
what if going from 200 to 50 square feet
we went from 200 to 100.
minimum square feet and then you know
100 square feet per two bed area
and an additional 50 square feet and not
gross square feet but square feet living
space
for rooms housing
uh more than two beds
i had two
problems with
with those numbers those original
numbers one is that it sounds to me more
like a purdue farm chicken factory
with people stacked on top of each other
i don't think that's good for the
residents
and the other thing is it
it could far more than double the
population in that residence which could
put a burden on the neighborhood
um
so i'll leave it that at that for now um
i just think perhaps some other more
generous formula
is needed in this
thank you thank you representative
alekas
thank you um so a couple of points one
is um
it does change it from being 200
for the whole building to 50 for the
sleeping area and
you know
having
people in a dormitory situation which in
college for a couple years i was in i
don't think i had any more maybe less
space than that
um it's just a place to sleep it's not
we're going to spend your whole day and
that's i think why the comparison to
the prison situation wasn't applicable
because there you're going to spend most
your day there
and there are other
constraints on the number of people and
the size of the whole
facility
because they have requirements as they
said for you know everybody's got to be
able to meet together and dine together
and there's other requirements that have
to be there so i really don't see a
problem with 50 square feet just for the
sleeping space and it's not 100 to 50 it
was or 250 it's 200 for the whole
building not just sleeping space going
on a 50 for the bed area sleeping area
so i mean i i fully support this bill as
it is
in terms of psyche
uh
we're not the experts on this we had the
fire marshal we had uh
uh
um
who else was in here uh jake berry
kimbach people who do this for a living
all the time and they're satisfied with
there was somebody else that besides uh
dallas andrew
they're the people that know about this
and it sounds like this was just an um
it meets uh
uh national standards um
i i i'm going to
representative lectures i think we
should well i'm agreeing with you i
think we should just
accept that this is an improvement
okay representative pearson
thank you madam chair i actually sat on
this commission
with senator del sandro so um and i'm
sorry i wasn't here for the
the whole shebang we
this this building's like a bee's nest
right now everybody's double booked
everywhere but
uh you know one of the things i want to
just just point out to all of you is
that you know you're you're looking at
what amounts to basically four pieces of
statute in a
overall
area of the code that is
dozens of pages long and i think that
there's a there's probably a little bit
of a context loss there in the sense
that
what you also don't see because you know
it's only
changing this one particular part so
that's what we see in front of us on the
bill
but you know as was reiterated in the
testimony you know there's restrictions
in reference to septic bathrooms
there's a lot of criteria that exists
that defines how these structures look
in as far as how many people you can put
in them and that's
i don't want that to get lost in the
weeds here without just having to focus
on
them wanting to do more of a dormitory
style
of sleeping arrangement than an overall
an overall encompassing one which we're
doing now which frankly is horrible it
doesn't work and the pack and stack
thing this doesn't create pack and stack
this gets rid of pack and stack
and
this this doesn't create pack and stack
it gets rid of it
right and one of the things that has
been concerning in my my profession in
the fire service
has been when these started popping up
we had no idea where they were there was
really no
standards of any kind it was it was kind
of a free-for-all that
that existed under this federal
shield if you will in that they became a
protected class and they just started
running rampant
without
you know every time a state tried to put
some restrictions they said oh well the
fed said we're you know we're a
protected class you can't do anything to
us
that wasn't entirely accurate but that
was the kind of the attitude when they
came storming into new hampshire and i
appreciate the testimony here
where the director of new hampshire core
is substantially different than she was
two years ago when she came before our
commission i'll tell you that right now
no doubt so
so like i said i just i don't want
i don't want us to get lost in this one
little part of of this change where it's
you know there's there's a clinical
aspect to what they're asking for here
it's it's not
just simply hey you know we want to do
50 50 you know typical dorm room size 50
feet
you know per
per sleeping room it's
there's more to it so
okay
brooks and o'brien and then fellows
thank you madam chair just very quickly
i couldn't agree more with
representative pearson
it's been my understanding with some of
these groups they are for profit to some
degree that they come into the community
and they offer this and uh like
representative pearson said my
experience on the fire department they
were popping up in neighborhoods hard to
find and everything else i find this
very much more regulatory plus it's
something that the industry itself needs
there is a need out there that we have
seen and i think this basically uh does
it so not to rehash what representative
pearson said but i'm in total agreement
with him thank you madam chair
representative fellows
um i'd just like to say that that um
representative allegro has a point about
the wording of this and if everybody's
in agreement
with the concept i'm willing to go get
an amendment to just change the wording
of this
and to say something really instead of
what it says here it would say each
bedroom shall have a minimum of 500
square feet per bid which i think is
more straightforward
not 500
i'm sorry you said 500 square feet which
is a very large bedroom that would be
nice but we can make it 50.
okay thank you that will
representative goalie and then bailey
i don't care much for the term gross i
mean you could substitute less than 50
feet by the meaning of that term the way
they're using that
um
it would be sufficient for me to amend
it to just strike out the word gross
representative allegro
yeah thank you i yeah so
that number 200 stuck in my head and i
was
clearly mistaken about that
can somebody on the committee says the
questions to anybody and everybody
present can somebody on the committee
just give me
you know put it in context to me we're
going from
200 square feet for an entire facility
to
you know we're comparing apples to
oranges can somebody compare oranges to
oranges for me just roughly anyway i
could do that if you want representative
pearson
so as it works right now
i think you know we've new hampshire's
notorious for building splits so let's
just go with a split because we all know
what a split level house looks like
when you take
when one of those is purchased and be in
becomes a recovery house to which no one
can stop i want to make that clear no
one they are federally protected it is
extr extraordinarily difficult to stop
that so it's going to happen right now
they'll look at that and say okay it's a
2 000 square foot house
based on this
no a 2 000 square foot house based on
this i can put 10 people in here
just off of this one particular line
where the where 153 kicks in in all the
other things is if you're on septic
there's no way you can do 10 people you
you i guarantee the place doesn't have a
septic system designed for that
there's other provisions that kick in in
the fire code in reference to
the definitions of boarding houses
versus single-family homes and those
sort of things
the certification agency
has
requirements you would have to have at
least two full baths which you might in
a ranch a split a split level ranch you
might have two full baths potentially
but now you're talking about the kitchen
part of it the there's like it's it's a
matrix of requirements so
rather than
come up with a gross number of for the
whole structure
keep in mind it says 10 but it's three
bedrooms
that's pack and stack
this takes the pack and stack element
out of it and says okay if you know if
i've got a split level range that's
three bedrooms
i can't put 10 people in it i i can put
far less
and you know that's the concern that the
fire service has had
in in certainly neighborhood groups and
folks like that of you know i have this
i'm in a single family neighborhood and
a recovery house shows up next door and
i've got 15 cars in the driveway
so this this is an impr i think this is
a huge improvement to the current
way that we can do things in the sense
that it's it's going to provide a more
restriction and it's a restriction that
the the regulatory agency is welcoming
so as far as i'm concerned that's
fantastic yeah instead of 10 people in
that house you'd probably get
four yeah
right
based on the size of the bedrooms okay i
mean you just basically answered my
question there really is no apples to
apples comparison in this but you're
feeling confident that this is going to
decrease the stacking
and that's why i asked to be on that
commission is because it
you know my concern is you know rolling
up with engine two at three o'clock in
the morning i got 10 people
crawling in the front yard from smoke
inhalation and people hanging out in
windows and we didn't even know this
place was here yeah that was my concern
and they exist and this is you know the
city of manchester could probably handle
that a whole lot differently than up
north
with the resources are far less so
you know i
i you know it's it's
it's not a secret that miss miss bach
and i have butted heads over this since
i got on the commission because when
they first came into it they came into
new hampshire they came in in a stock
car and they were just ramming their way
through things and this you know things
have changed in two years a lot and
they're starting to understand that new
hampshire
isn't really interested in playing the
game the way they thought it was going
to be played here so this is this is a
huge improvement yeah i can support that
i would just recommend with
representative bailey that we strike the
word gross from this and just deal with
floor space and just
square feet
representative goalie
thank you madam chair and
i i just want to
state that i mean we heard
as representative pearson said that they
have come in here stating as a
protective class
and
one of the things and one of the issues
this was brought before us and you heard
it from the fire marshal that the 200
square feet that they initially did was
because they didn't know where to go
when they started looking through the
statutes they came out with a dormitory
number
well in
square feet is the dormitory number
fifty-five per bed no it was for
something 200 it was from single family
single family
thank you
the
by picking that number with nothing
entailed
these folks are coming in
declaring discriminatory nature because
we're picking a number out of nowhere
and this is where
they
in speaking with these folks went to a
national number that's being used
nationally so now there's no discrepancy
and there's no discrimination against
these folks because we're using the
national standard that is going by them
that's why this is here if we start
changing this language now we're going
away from that national standard the way
it's worded nationally across the
country which we haven't heard
any problems with
so i ask that you keep the language as
it is
and not change it there is nobody here
testifying that it isn't working across
the
country thank you
representative o'brien and then bailey
ah thank you madam chair i would just
like to state that um i heard testimony
by senator d'alessandro this will bring
it up as representative gulley mentioned
national standards jake barry said the
same thing what is the national standard
when you come down to occupancies and
such
you're under the guidelines of the nfpa
the national fire protection association
i have been a veteran of a couple of
battles in nashua when does a rectory
become a roaming house or when does a
you know climate become a roaming house
and looking at some of those type of
issues there to strike anything i'm sure
when you have the fire marshal come up
and sit here before us he has to do some
detailed work into looking in in the
proper language and i think to gross and
to strike it
i just cautioned that
uh without a dnfa book
in front of me i cannot say striking out
anything with jeopardize would not
jeopardize this i'm gonna rely on the
expertise of the state fire marshal and
leave the language as correctly in
support not support any changes
representative bailey well i i seem to
recall that nobody could define growth
for me representative allegro provided
that
but
a second when you talked about stacking
it puts in mind what prevents you from
doubling this with bunk beds
it's per person
so there's they still have 50 feet of
space this is not we're not we're not
landing airplanes this is the floor
space yeah so you can't if you have a
100 square foot bedroom you could put in
a bunk bed
thank you
i just i i i find find it hard to
believe that there's some kind of
guidance somewhere that has this exact
wording i mean it just is so
convoluted
that that
that there's a guidance somewhere that
says the facility shall have a minimum
gross square feet per bed per sleeping
room i just can't imagine it's worth
it's awarded like that uh well you
you're not as familiar with building
codes and the this the fire code as some
some of our other members i worked for
the nfpa i was a technical advisor for
them
and
if i put the fire codes in their
entirety on this table
it's two and a half feet
so so
the this type of language is is is
exactly what you find in codes for a
reason it's so if they're talking about
this the square footage in a bedroom why
is the word facility in there
because recovery houses see this is this
is the problem that you have in the
recovery house world in the sense that
that when it's convenient for them
they're a facility and when it's
convenient for them they're an exempt
protected class single family home and
they stay and when it's convenient they
say they're a family that's right and
they and they and that's one of the
problems that i've the beefs that i've
had with new hampshire corps from the
beginning is they very conveniently kind
of swing between the two things when
it's convenient so sometimes they are a
facility
where the code where the national the
fire code kicks in is that boarding
houses are looked at in a very different
world than a treatment type of a center
and that's why the word facility comes
into play okay i'm just trying to like
make it
normal english
no no no the the codes don't use normal
english
it's rather stylized yes i mean i'm
serious i worked i worked on engineering
codes and they're the same way yeah i'm
sure do you
okay representation i just can't believe
they have the growth thank you madam
chair i just want to want to bring us
back around to the to the center here
we're actually discussing it not to pass
motion and i and i feel like we're
getting hung up in words of a possible
amendment when we're
we're actually we're debating and ought
to pass on
house bill 223 so if ever i don't know
if i'm gonna is that where i'm at
senate bill senate bill my bad
um
so just
kind of wanna redirect our efforts here
and see if we can
and we can vote
i would not support an amendment to
change that okay
is it is there anyone else who wishes to
comment
well i i think
yes might not be a bad idea before we
complete this
just to double check that our
understanding i mean we got a lot of
expertise here and experience so i'm i'm
i'm not hospital that testimony at all
we could we could
ask a question or two just to confirm
that
if everybody's on board with that but
otherwise i think that the language that
we're seeing here is the language that
the fire marshal you know the
person who has the responsibility in the
state for this has testified in support
of so i'm happy to go forward with that
just just to run the idea of
asking a question or two before we
finalize the vote
does any and how how many people think
we need to wait and gather more
information
yeah
i'm ready to vote on it
okay there's three people that think we
want to wait so
i think we will perceive
that okay
um
so the motion is ought to pass by
representative goalie seconded by
representative schmidt
and the clerk can call the roll
representative rhodes yes
the clerk votes yes representative
pearson yes
representative jakubovic yes
representative lekkis yes
representative allegro yes
representative bailey
no
representative goalie
yes
representative schuett yes
representative
schmidt
did you call me i didn't hear it schmidt
yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative
o'brien
yes
the chair
yes a lot to
one uh 14 i think
13 to 1 13. 13. all right
somebody oh that's right
representing broda stepped out she had
another meeting
uh right do you object to consent
representative bailey no okay in that
case we'll put it on consent if and no
one else objects
all right
and since we're
and i have an amendment to senate bill
398 that i would like to move
um
where that amendment go
it's heard of that a minute ago
it is amendment number
h and if anyone doesn't have it i've got
some more copies here
if it's not on get your place that means
you probably didn't get it
i'll pass it around
here you go pass those around oh yeah
well we discussed this this amendment
merely moves
uh well
procedurally speaking i'm going to move
out to pass with the amendment is there
a second second
second thank you representative goldie
all right so the amendment is 1329 h
and that repeat simply deletes the
section talking about
the effectivity of the building code
because we covered it more thoroughly
in
13 1681
yeah houseboat 1681 which is marching
through the senate
it's in the second committee
and for people who don't like
study committees this bill takes an
existing and ineffective committee
re-titles it and repurposes it to
something that's useful
represent goalie
thank you madam chair right very well
said and i think this
just strikes out that section you
explain thank you
any other comments on the amendment well
we're all reading it
okay i don't see any
madam chair if uh if i may having
spent a bit of time testifying over in
the senate
one of the common questions that the
senate asks is if the
if the when the immense stop as if the
sponsor of the original bill was okay
with the amendment
so i guess i'll ask you is senator
carson okay with this
well she was here when we discussed
deleting that section and she didn't
make any objection to it every the other
people who were testifying
the building code review board and the
fire marshal both said that the
wording in 1681 was
was better than what's in here this was
just kind of a
built-in suspenders
cool very good thank you
anyone else
uh just to clarify
the testimony of the both fire marshal
and mr sherman who was the chair of the
building code review board or something
like that both wanted lines 23 to 29
removed is that what your amendment does
yes sir exactly that section 1 ends at
line 22
so then it goes into this change and
then the effective date
the comment is the same okay thank you
anyone else
all right in that case the most
the motion before us is to adopt
amendment
1329h to senate bill 398 and the clerk
can call the roll
who is the second
sorry goalie
representative rhodes yes clerk wrote
yes representative pearson yes
representative yakovich yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes
representative bailey
yes representative goalie yes
representative schuett
yes
representative schmidt
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes representative no
he's not here sorry representative
o'brien yes
and the chair yes 14 to nine zero
one amendment in that case i move ought
to pass with amendment on senate bill
second
wow represent a goalie okay
i think
enough's been said by me representative
okay
it doesn't represent pearson i have a
question the
you said this modifies an existing
board so we're not we're not adding
another
another one to the pile of 200 would
already have the three members of the
of the house two of which shall be edna
who are the current edna members that
sit on that board
you told you it was inactive and
ineffective
so we don't we don't even know who sits
on the
i don't believe it's done anything in a
long time so this so it hasn't been
sapped by the by the speaker of the
house
no yeah no
yeah it replaces a joint committee on
code enforcement which
with the this advisory committee and
that will is something this was a
recommendation of the study committee
last year
that about building codes so this will
let us get started on code updates in a
timely manner
anyone else rep ah thank you
representative allegra
thank you i just had a couple of
questions and concerns but again they
may be based on a misunderstanding so
i'm going to put them out and ask for
clarification
if i understood correctly this is
going to reduce the involvement of the
legislature
and
am i wrong on that interrupt me please
it's not going to reduce the involvement
of the legislature okay it will in fact
increase it
into the inner workings of the building
code review board and the fire control
board because
instead of getting a bill every couple
of years thrown at us
we'd be this committee would be meeting
with the building code review board and
the board of fire control to see
in the process of making amendments to
them okay yeah my concern was that we're
taking power away from legislature
putting more in the hands of the
executive branch but
um
thank you for that clarification and
then the other thing and this is minor
it's not gonna well it's not minor
but it's uh and it's not going to
interfere with my vote on this
but just the testimony that uh regarding
making it harder for trades people
um to have to go from town to town
this doesn't affect that at all
so where did that come in ah that was
in the original bill before the senate
deleted it okay
i'm good thank you it's yeah the
1681 also has a statement where towns
have to provide their
amendments the building code to the
building code review board which will
publish them that will help the
tradesman going from town to town it
won't help the fact that i think hudson
wants one type of electrical cable and
pelham wants a different one
but that's their problem yeah thank you
my antennae just went up because i
didn't think that that
bit of testimony held a lot of yeah
sharon's testimony i'm afraid kind of
muddled
the two or three bills that came out of
that study committee and this bill as
amended by the senate is
a lot simpler than what we started with
okay
anyone else represent fellows
um i just had a question about why um
the membership of the house is
two people from edna i i understand that
one person from finance i'm just
thinking that really the people you want
on the committee are people who know if
i understand fire codes and understand
building codes
i'm not sure why finance either except
they're
generally familiar with all sorts of
things they may be familiar with with
the
state procurement process and bill and
the buildings that we put up
but
you're familiar with money signature
they're familiar with money too so it's
uh
yeah i'm not sure why either i wasn't
consulted finance always wants to have
their mitts in everything
and you need somebody other than needing
to e-dna with another point of view i
think yeah we definitely want somebody
different
but
i i i'm not sure who else it would be i
mean just anyone in general would be
well i was just thinking in terms of if
it just said and somebody appointed by
the speaker then you would assume they'd
appoint somebody who
had knowledge and area maybe
perhaps i
share your concern but i don't think
it's worth fighting for and if if you'd
been if we thought about it we could
have deleted that when i made the other
amendment
but sorry about that madam chair when
this leaves edna is this going to
finance nope okay
just not an early
bill
and the other representative schmidt
having observed the inner workings of
the edna committee uh and the building
code review board there's another one
what's the one that
that ransomware what's his name
ranford i think rancor ran court that's
his name um
there's something here contractors know
what i'm talking about having observed
the inner workings and the
i think that this bill really has the
possibility this construct has a
possibility of enhancing the the
cooperation and collaboration and also
that you don't
find out that some they're off there
doing something that we don't like or
they're we're doing something they don't
like
this collaboration i think really could
improve the process a lot and i think
it's definitely worth a try
thank you
i'll jump off of that for those that
that have not been on edna very long
there were times in this room where the
where there was a war going on in the
seats over there
literally because the groups were not on
the same page
and when this when the last group of
changes rolled through here and every
single group came up here and was this i
couldn't believe what i was that never
happened like so
if we can have some collaboration before
it gets into this room with this stuff
and that's what this appears to be doing
i think that's going to make life easier
for
for the legislature
as a whole to not have to sit in front
of a war between the building trades in
this room and also it's that's a war
that most of us are not really
that competent to to figure out who's
right and who's wrong and if they agree
then we're much happier
okay you get the attorneys for the uh
the builders associations
and so forth and so on and and uh
members of the house who are themselves
attorneys sometimes involved in these
issues in addition to their legislative
responsibilities uh and it is
it's a kind of a toxic stew
okay representative goalie
thank you madam chair i just will say
been there done that and we'll be glad
to put it behind us
you bet all right anyone else comments
questions
all right representative
if i may have a point of personal
privilege for a moment
last friday i bailed three guys from
yonkers
who were in salem to steal grease from a
grease trap at a restaurant
by the way
interesting used to be garbage now it's
i'm glad i'm on edna i know all about it
i need bigger crops
well you know a little trap just isn't
worth the bother of stealing
price of fuel
you got that pizza from where
two yonkers one bronx
ah thank you all right
all right anyone else comments in that
case
the motion is ought to pass with
amendment on how to senate bill 398 and
the clerk can call the rule
representative rhodes yes the clerk
votes yes representative pearson yes
representative yaakovich yes
representative yes representative
allegro yes representative bailey yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewit yes
representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes representative
fellows yes
representative o'brien yes
the chair
yes
i guess we're 14-0
all right does anyone object to consent
okay we'll put that on consent and i'll
write the report
is there anyone who feels like to making
a motion on senate bill 460 or senate
bill 356.
those were the other ones we heard today
460. yeah okay
representative lekkis moves ought to
pass on
senate bill 460. i'll
be happy to second that if you need okay
do you wish to speak to your motion
uh just briefly um i think we had a
pretty good explanation of what's going
on there i'm satisfied i understand why
there's no fiscal note it makes sense
and uh
it's a a generally good idea to have
people's title have something to do with
what they're actually doing so that's it
okay robin pearson
i fully agree with representative lekkis
i i certainly was concerned when they're
talking about how the system that was
put into place was done in the 1930s
and uh you know
clearly at some point they're going to
need to look at
um
at this this whole venture you know i
mean as he said they have a thousand
positions that now have enhancements so
it clearly tells you that this this
system is is definitely antiquated so
you know but until such time as we come
up with something else this is what we
have in place and it needs to function
so
here we are okay represent goalie
thank you madam chair and
i agree especially about those
enhancements when we talk about um
what the state is paying some of its
employees and
as i was out and about this weekend and
stopped at
a local
establishment and saw that they had on
their doors a posting looking for
uh hiring cashiers and checkers and
starting at twelve dollars and change an
hour
i thought was
pretty pathetic
looking at our state agency actually
putting that on their front door
when you can see signs out there for
dunkin donuts mcdonald's and other
places paying well over that so there is
needed change
okay this is a small step
all right anyone else
okay the motion is ought to pass on
senate bill 460 and the clerk can call
the roll
representative rhodes yes
clerk votes yes representative pearson
yes
representative
representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes representative
goalie
yes representative stewart
yes representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows yes
representative o'brien
yes the chair yes
what do you know
okay does anyone object to consent
okay
represent yes representative
with respect to commissioner
arlinghaus's presentation
i heard all that
at jcec and if i had real powers of
recollection i could have said it all i
forgot it once i'll probably forget it
again it's disappointing okay
well i think it's important for us to to
hear from the commissioner with regard
to some of these issues because
his office is the one especially now
that
pam smarling is no longer the staffer
for the jcec
but
commissioner arlinghaus is the one whose
office coordinates all these
incoming questionnaires and documents
and so forth which then
go to the
corn fairy hay group and if they come
back
with a recommendation
that endorsed endorses the
the request of the agency then
the
jcec's executive function is to approve
that
it gets the politic partisan politics
out of it that you know causing a lot of
problems
several decades ago
um but then it's the edna committee's
responsibility to put that change in the
statute then it goes to finance for
financing and so forth so it is an
antiquated system but as representative
pearson said uh it it is working and the
ministerial function of the jcec
works and representative scitec and i
have been on it for more than 10 years
so we've seen it in action so thank you
for your support of it
okay
cleaning up representative lekkis moves
ought to pass on senate bill 356 the
medical benefits payments
is there a second a second
okay like i said o'brien
we should speak to your motion sure um
i think this is pretty straightforward
it aligns the billing and renewal and
expiration policy
with um you know the federal
requirements and i don't always support
federal requirements but looking at it i
think it looks reasonable and um
you know if we want to stay uh you know
getting the federal money from uh
medicare um so and i don't see you know
anything particularly bad about these
um and they're from my experience
typical for other insurance policies if
you stop paying them you you stop
getting coverage and you've got to start
up again so i don't see anything
objectionable here okay representative
o'brien uh for brevity i couldn't agree
with the representative lekkers thank
you excellent is there
anyone else who wish to comment on this
okay
that was that was smooth in that case
the motion is ought to pass on senate
bill 356
by representative lackas
the clerk can call the role
representative rhodes yes
clark ports yes representative pearson
yes representative yakovich yes
representative
yes representative allegro yes
representative bailey yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett
yes representative schmidt yes
representative marsh yes
representative fellows
yes
representative o'brien yes and the chair
excuse me
slytherin uh
was she here when the question is yes
she was here when the referee was here
for most of the debate as well yes
fifteen oh if you must know
i vote yes by them
dude i didn't know wait a minute i
thought did i didn't i call you and then
oh
you started to and then representative
grota pointed out she had been
overlooked but that's okay
all right any
uh
anyone object to consent
okay good we'll put that one on consent
too uh representative lekis and goalie
the
sooner the better with your with your
committee reports no later than friday
and representative pearson is going to
enjoy senate bill 397
okay
in that case we've
we've finished everything we can do
today so
have a nice afternoon guys
well we're going to be here friday so
you can hand it to me if you don't want
to email it
yes we're going to be here on friday so
yes the beginning of the day would be
fine
not 10 p.m no no
friday
you